so it's come to my attention very
recently that people absolutely love
tokyo avengers and want to know anything
and everything that happens throughout
this amazing series but don't
necessarily have the time to read this
series or they just want to know
everything now so today to fix that i'm
going to spill the beans and go over the
entire tokyo avengers story in depth
which will consist of us going through
each arc starting with the tomen
introduction arc all the way up to the
most recent complete arc which is the
bontine arc but just before we get into
the video if you are new around here and
want to keep up to date with the latest
tokyo avengers content then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and also
be sure to leave a like on the video as
it really helps out with the algorithm
and pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
sit back and enjoy as this is going to
be a very long video about an absolutely
amazing story
one day takamichi hanagaki while
watching the news finds out that his
middle school girlfriend hinata
tachybana has been killed in a tokyo
manji gang conflict alongside her
brother naoto after a terrible day at
work and running off from an angry
salary man whose car takamichi had
coined he starts to reflect on his life
while waiting at the train station he
thinks about his lousy life from his
living space and job to his cowardice
and the fact that he is simply a yes man
never questioning or standing up for
himself suddenly someone pushes him onto
the train tracks and as he stares at the
incoming train his life starts to flash
before his eyes and he thinks of hina
and his second year of middle school
regarding it as the peak of his life
after a bright flash of light takamichi
finds himself on a train in shibuya
surrounded by middle school friends
makoto yamagashi akun and takuya they
tell takamichi to leave the train with
them commenting on his strange behavior
as takamichi reacts to his lame
appearance he looks at his phone and
finds out that it's july 4th 2005
exactly 12 years ago as he walks around
the school searching for second years
takamiji starts to recall the events
that occurred while thinking a group of
third years led by kiyosama appear
kiyosama reveals that the second years
are on a school trip when yamageshi
mentions marasu's name the group laughs
takamichi remembers that marasu lied
about being a leader to show off when in
all reality he was merely an errand boy
they are all then brutally beaten by
kyosama and his group walking home with
his defeated friends takamichi suddenly
remembers hina and runs to her apartment
as he struggles to remember how she
looked hina scolds him for fighting
takamichi tears upon seeing her and is
reminded of his feelings that he has for
her after leaving hina takamichi arrives
at a nearby park to reflect but is
interrupted by a group of bullies
bullying a boy enraged them for ruining
his moment he scares away the bullies as
he and the boy talk takamichi finds out
that the boy is naototachibana
hina's younger brother takamichi
confesses his love for hina then tells
neyoto that he will die alongside his
sister in 12 years he tells naoto to
remember that date asking him to promise
to protect his sister after this naruto
and takamichi shake hands on the
agreement takamichi awakes in the train
station's medical center back in the
present an employee informs him that a
certain individual saved him who turns
out to be a grown-up naoto after
introducing himself naoto tells
takamichi that he changed the future
through a time leap after his encounter
with takamichi naoto studied hard to
protect his sister becoming a police
detective however naruto's efforts were
for nothing as hina still ended up dying
he asks takamichi to work with him to
try and save hina after takamichi agrees
to help naoto save hina he spends two
days absorbing a huge amount of
information about the tokyo manji gang
naoto confirms the gang's dangerousness
and exclaims that his predecessors
obtained the information at the brutal
cost of his life because takamichi's
time-lipping powers are limited to
exactly 12 years naruto says takamichi's
mission is to prevent the amazing of the
current tokyo mangy's top two manjuro
sano and tetekisaki as the current gang
that killed hina would not exist if
those two do not meet takamichi
speculates that the time leaping trigger
is a handshake after they both shake
hands takamichi finds himself facing
another boy in a fight surrounded by
spectators shocked takamichi checks his
phone and confirms that he is leaped 12
years back it is now july 6 2005. while
distracted takamichi's opponent punches
him knocking him out completely coming
too takamichi finds kiyosama's gang
around him they scold takamichi for
losing early as kiyosama's profits from
the bets depend on the fight's
entertainment as punishment for his weak
performance one of kiyosama's underlings
beat takamichi during his beating
takamichi recalls that his abuse at
kiyosama's hands caused him to run away
from his circumstances leading to his
pathetic current life
after dealing takamichi his punishment
kiyosama and his underlings begin to
leave however takamichi calls after them
requesting to meet either of the gang's
leaders sano or kisaki angered by his
request kiyosama brutally beats
takamichi with a bat and tells him not
to say sano's name again or he will be
killed terrified takamichi concludes
that his mission is impossible and
dangerous he arrives at the tachibana
household to return to the present as he
waits outside he wonders if he is
running away
the next day takamichi and his friends
meet in the bathroom to discuss the
day's fight takuya who is frail and a
weak fighter will fight today although
they are willing to fight in takuya's
place kiyosama will likely disregard
them after a discussion between a bunch
of the guys there takamichi is extremely
impressed as he realizes the devotion
and care of his friends heading towards
the fight the crowd eagerly awaits with
the odds against takuya just as kiyosama
starts the fight takamichi interrupts he
says that it is boring seeing the same
fights every day and suggests a more
entertaining format a king versus his
slave kiyosama agrees to fight takamichi
but takamichi soon realizes the
difference in power after kiyosama's
first hurt while kiyosama continues his
assault takamichi refuses to accept his
loss even at the urging of his concerned
friends eventually the crowd falls
silent shocked by takamichi's resolve
takamichi declared that he must change
himself for the bitter and stop running
away from adversity he tells kiyosama
that the only way he will lose is if he
is killed furious he osama shouts for
his bat promising to do so
suddenly tokyo manji gang's vice
commander ken ryoguji also known as
draken interrupts the fire behind him an
extremely mysterious boy follows who
turns out to be the tokyo magi gang's
commander manjiro sano also known as
just mikey as everyone present quickly
bows greasing him
ignoring the rest of the delinquents the
two gang heads walk towards kiyosama and
takamichi as kiersama bows draken kicks
him in the stomach remarking on his
arrogance approaching takamichi mikey
asks if he really is a middle schooler
and then mikey asks his name when
takamichi responds mikey pronounces his
name as takamichi and declares them as
friends turning to kiyosama mikey asks
if he is the one organizing the fight
club after kiyosama responds
affirmatively mikey kicks him or they
smile before knocking him out with a
punch while the crowd watches in shock
draken tells them not to bring toman's
reputation down and mikey smiling at
takamichi promises that they will meet
again
takamichi returns to the present day and
is joined by naruto at a construction
site where mobius's former leader osanai
is working hoping that they can question
the man about the conflict between
mobius and toman after questioning osana
naoto and takamichi determined that
somebody was working to turn mikey and
draken against one another and takamichi
needs to return to the past in order to
prevent tomen from fighting against
mobius when he returns to the past he's
riding on the back of a tushie's bicycle
and he inquires about what akun's dreams
are akun says that he wants to become a
beautician and takamichi insists that he
must become one and that he'll be his
first customer when he does after
getting to where the tomin guys are
takamichi interrupts an important
discussion between mikey drakken par and
pay asking if the conflict between
mobius can be stopped par tells him to
leave but takamichi keeps insisting even
as he's beaten up over trying to prevent
the conflict mikey tells him that it has
already decided that tomon and mobius
will fight takamichi continues to refuse
to back down and drakken prevents path
from hitting him again mikey asks dracon
if he's defying tomen when he says maybe
it's a good idea to listen to takamichi
and see what mobius is up to after all
before the argument can escalate they
are interrupted by osanai park
immediately tries to hit him but is
punched instead and osana says that he'd
heard tomen was going to pick a fight
with mobius and decided to come over and
strike first mobius gang members fled
into the building as osanai declares war
takamichi reflects on the differences
between this osana and the presideo
sinai and while staring at him winds up
getting punched by osanai parr
interrupts the fight saying that osano's
fight is with him while takamichi tries
to get him to stop payan tells takamichi
that par isn't weak and there's no way
that he is going to lose against osanai
and even though takamichi is worried for
other reasons than that mike insists
that he sit back and watch when the
fight starts to look bad for par payan
runs in but is stopped in his tracks by
mikey telling him to sit back and watch
because even though par is looking worse
for wear he hasn't given up yet when par
is no longer able to stand mikey steps
in to support him telling him there's no
need to apologize because the fight
isn't lost yet then he swiftly takes
osana down stating that nothing will
ever take tomend down because it belongs
to him while dracon is complimenting
mikey for not backing down i sinai
stands back up and tries to stab mikey
but draken steps in to stop the knife
draken dispatches osanai preventing him
from stabbing mikey and tells osana that
he lost because he strayed from the path
of a true delinquent he then tells the
other members of mobius that their boss
was beaten by mikey and from here on out
mobius will be affiliated with tomen
hearing police sirens in the distance
everyone decides that they need to
escape and draken insists that somebody
carries asanai out parchin stabs osanai
while he's down as the police draw
closer par tells everybody to escape
without him because he's going to give
himself up to the police
while leaving takamichi collapses and
wakes up later on in the hospital where
emma is at his bedside she tells him
that draken and mikey have started
fighting and it is torn toeman in two
with the group fighting over whether
parchin deserve to be arrested or not
after finishing their puzzle at home
takamichi's friends atushi takuya
yamagishi and suzuki come to visit
talking about the recent conflict with
mobius he asks them if mikey and draken
have been fighting and they tell him
they are but it's nothing serious at
this point draken enters the room and
they sit around and talk about how parr
won't be released from prison for at
least a year and that osana is still
alive when takamichi asks about mikey
draken slams his fist down destroying
the puzzle takamichi worked on for three
entire days and declares before leaving
that he's going to sever connections
with mikey outside they bump into mikey
who had been on his way to visit
takamichi as well
as he and draken begin arguing and
physically fighting throwing around
takamichi's belongings after they have
destroyed many of his precious things
takamichi angud orders them to stop
takamiji swings at mikey after being
annoyed that draken and mikey were
thrown around his things while they
argued mikey dodges and takamichi winds
up toppling into a pile of garbage when
he stands up he becomes emotional and
starts yelling at the two of them for
destroying his things and not caring
about people around them at the end of a
speech mikey comments that takamichi has
poop stuck in his hair and the serious
atmosphere disappears and everybody
laughs later dracon and mikey apologize
to one another and mikey says that he
forgot why they were even fighting when
takamichi asks about it takamichi comes
to an understanding that mikey wanted to
help parchin and drakken didn't want
parr's decision to turn himself into
police to be in vain mikey says that
they should have a huge party when par
is released and takamichi realizes that
he's stopped drackett and mikey from
fighting and so that means draken won't
die on august the 3rd hina and emma show
up where all the boys are gathered and
tina asks takamichi if he will go with
her to a festival on the third which he
agrees to
takamichi and hina end up joining draken
and emma at the festival and hina talks
about how hard emma is trying to get
draken to notice her even going as far
to make him jealous by using takamichi
and she says that she'll forgive
takamichi for that if he wins her a
grand prize at one of the festival
booths but he is unable to win anything
from the rigged game it starts raining
and takamichi and hina retreat into the
tree line takamichi helps hina walk as
her sandals are the wrong size putting
her in pain they embrace each other but
when they're about to kiss hina
interrupts takamichi and tells him that
his phone is ringing is yamagishi
telling takamichi to tell dracon to be
careful because he's received some intel
that some of the atomian members who
support mikey are targeting him
takamichi tells hina to weigh and runs
off to go tell draken getting annoyed at
himself at the same time for letting
down his own guard on his way he sees a
member of mobius talking to kyomasa who
states aloud that he's going to kill
draken the mobius member gives kyomasa a
knife while watching kiyomasu takamichi
is discovered and dragged before him by
another tomen member he is pushed and
kicked around and realizes that despite
hanging out with mikey it hasn't made
him any stronger and he's still useless
and scared in this situation unable to
do anything hiromasa and his underlings
wrap takamichi up in duct tape and tells
takamichi that when they're done killing
draken they'll be back to make him pay
for what he did he defines way takamichi
is bound and he cries over not being
able to help or save anyone in order to
stop him from carrying on or yelling
about his uselessness hina kisses him
remarking that she's giving him her
first kiss and tells him that he's a
very special person even if he can't do
what mikey or draken do takamichi thanks
her for snapping him out of her and
leaves to settle the score with kyomasa
as he's going to track down kyomasa
takamichi runs into mitsuya and tells
him that draken is going to be attacked
matsuya tells him that he already knows
but while takamichi is convinced that
kyomasa is the one that that's going to
do it matsuya says that it's actually
payan even though mikey and draken had
resolved their conflict payan is still
unhappy about paz arrest and how nothing
was done about her thinking that toman
abandoned par payan approaches dracon
and emma and draken is also ambushed
from behind takamichi recalls the naoto
of the present day saying that draken
was killed in a brawl and a parking lot
and leads matsuya there where they find
draken has taken down a lot of the
mobius members who would attacked him
but has been heavily injured in the
process matsuya and emma call it
sepayaan calling him a coward for coming
after drakken with an entire gang like
this and draken tells metsuya to take
care of the rest of mobius for him as
takamichi realizes that kyomasa isn't
around and that he's going to be made to
fight against mobius members draken
points out that the sound in the
distance is mikey approaching on his cb
250t mikey arrives and pieces together
the enemy's plan to break up tomon he
was called to a different area to
isolate draken as mikey asks payan who
manipulated him hanma arrives as the
temporary leader of mobius spurring
mikey to kick him however hanuman blocks
his kick and orders the mobius members
to kill both mikey and draken with the
goal of destroying tomen as takamichi
contemplates the unexpected developments
all of tomon arrives prepared to unite
to fight mobius as the fight begins
takamishi is determined to protect
dracon despite the unexpected
developments and looks for him amid the
fighting mikey confronts payan
questioning why he attacks draken payan
reiterates his anger at past perceived
abandonment and tells mikey to fight him
back mikey reminds payan of this
situation's seriousness from pa's arrest
to toman's potential split he thinks of
his personal selfishness which takamichi
has caused him to reflect on telling
payan to beat him up until he is
satisfied mikey tells pad that he does
not want to fight and asks him to rejoin
tomen as payan and mikey concile
takamichi finds draken on the ground
right after kyomasa stabs him realising
draken's injury is serious and that
kiramasa had stabbed him mikey orders
takamichi to take care of draken while
the fight with mobius continues while
takamichi attempts to carry draken to
the hospital emma and hina inform him
that they've called an ambulance as they
wait for the ambulance in an alleyway
kyomasu's group suddenly show up
takamichi briefly considers running away
and despite his stab wound drakken tells
him to leave with emma and hina this
order reminds takamichi of his goal of
saving those he cares for and because of
this his determination is renewed
motivating him to stand against kiromasa
takamichi declares his resolve to fight
kyomasa mentioning that they never
finished their fight in the ring
drakenheena and emma threw words of
support behind takamichi as he prepares
to punch kiramasa but kiramasa impales
his palm with a knife that he pulls out
from his back telling takamichi that he
has no intention of fighting fairly and
is prepared to kill him
pulling the knife out of his palm
takamichi thinks back to his aspirations
which was to become not only tokyo but
one of japan's top delinquents alongside
his middle school friends as he is
thrown onto the ground by kyomasa he
remembers his past weaknesses and
cowardice and rushes towards kyomasa
once more lacking in fighting ability
takamichi grabs onto kyomasa resorting
to biting and puts him under a chokehold
determined not to let go after holding
kiramasa in a chokehold takamichi
successfully subdues him however the
rest of kyomasu's group remains
takamichi tells hina and emma to leave
while he and dracon prepare to fight
despite this significantly weakened
state as they stand up to face their
opponents they are prepared to die with
takamishi asking draken what heaven will
be like chuckling dracon replies with
that they are going to hell despite this
they face their opponents with
determination
and takamichi reflects on his failure to
save drakon while still driven to do his
best suddenly akun appears and punches
one of their opponents in his face
coming to takamichi and draken's aid
alongside makoto kazushi and akon
kazushi makuso takuya and akun prepare
to fight the rest of kyomasu's group but
they are no match one of them remarks
that takamichi's friends are wasting
their time and takamichi apologizes to
draken for failing to protect him while
reflecting on his failures and achieving
his mission in response to the comment
regarding wasting their time atushi and
the rest of takamichi's friends remember
takamichi's perseverance against
kiramasa and expressed their drive to
win hearing the arrival of the ambulance
and police takamichi thanks his friends
and kyomasu's group leaves in a panic
leaving behind an unconscious kyomasa
takamichi is glad his actions were not
in vain and his friends helped dracon to
the ambulance
meanwhile tomin successfully defeats
mobius with hanma the sole member
standing hanuman remarks on the dullness
of this fight with mikey then leaves on
a motorcycle before his departure hanuma
tells mikey that valhalla the soon to be
strongest biker gang alliance and kanto
is about to form with hanma as one of
its vice leaders and that tomen will not
know peace as a result inside the
ambulance draken's severe condition
becomes evident before going into
cardiac arrest draken thanks takamichi
and tells him to take care of mikey
forum as this is happening mikey drives
to the hospital draken arrives at the
hospital in critical condition and is
immediately operated on hina and emma
alongside with takamichi and his middle
school friends wait anxiously
remembering the uncertainty of draken's
conditions as confirmed by the doctors
matsuya and payan arrive at the hospital
both anxious about dracon mikey arrives
shortly after and calmly reassures
everyone that dracon will survive as
they promise to own japan together he
implores them to stop worrying and
believe in drakken takamichi remarks to
himself that mikey is mentally strong
the surgery is a success and drakken
survives to everyone's relief as they
rejoice matsuya prepares to tell the
rest of tomen waiting outside the
hospital and payan expresses his shame
and his actions but masuya reassures him
that toman understands his motives his
loyalty departure matsuya also reveals
that draken has been going to visit par
in prison despite not being allowed to
see him face to face demonstrating the
care he showed for par he tells payan to
apologize to everyone especially draken
and par but is happy that payan rejoined
tomen as takamichi and the rest step out
of the hospital emma remarks that august
the 3rd has already passed meaning that
takamichi's achieved his mission to save
dracon outside as tomin rejoices
takamichi notices that maki is missing
he finds mikey alone breaking down out
of relief after finding out that draken
had survived takamichi realizes that
mikey had his true feelings of worry to
treasure everyone else's despite being
the most worried a week after the fight
between tom and mobius takamichi has
gained brief fame and respect because of
his ability to stop tome and splitting
as well as his victory over kyomasa and
because of this he has let it all go to
his head dressing in a flashy outfit and
acting all arrogant as noted by draken
when takamichi visits him in the
hospital there draken gives him mikey's
first time in uniform as mikey wanted
him to have her draken says takamichi is
tomen's savior and thanks him again
takamichi realizes the significance of
receiving mikey's uniform and draken
tells him to talk to him
finding mikey reflecting on the conflict
and possible events to come takamichi
panics when mikey wonders how he knew
about dracon's danger beforehand
takamishi is then relieved when mikey
shifts his focus onto his fleshy outfit
after mahi thanks takamichi for saving
draken takamichi leaves fahini's
apartment to shake hands with naoto and
return to the future as the mission has
been successful he admits to himself
that he would be content staying in the
past with his friends and arrives at
heena's door where she remarks that he
always shows up at weird times before
takamichi shakes naoto's hand he gives
hina a four-leaf clover necklace telling
her it is an apology for involving her
and the tomen mobius conflict naoto
shows up and him and takamichi both
shake hands while at the same time
takamichi tells hina to have a good life
as he returns to the future takamichi
hopes that the fates of those he cares
about will have changed since he
fulfilled his mission he returns to the
prison in the middle of his part-time
job where his manager confronts him
takamichi searches his phone for news of
hina's death but does not find any
though he wonders if the timeline was a
dream the scar on his right hand reminds
him of the reality of the events he then
flees from his job so that he can
process the events takamichi remembers
that he was previously fired from his
job before and cannot find naruto's
phone number on his phone a notification
on his phone brings him to a hair salon
where he is shocked to find akun who has
become a hair stylist in training akun
reminds takamichi of his promise to be
his first customer and takamichi reacts
to this with emotion elated that he
changed the future naoto calls takamichi
and congratulates him on a successful
mission and tells takamichi to visit
hina with him as he rides in naoto's car
takamichi thinks back to his feelings of
helplessness when he learned about
haena's death takamichi excitedly thinks
about missing hina while naoto tells him
that the incident that killed hina the
tomen dispute did not occur in this
current future takamichi envisions hina
still being thrilled to see him but he
reminds himself of the realism of the
situation
suddenly nervous he tells nyoto that he
cannot see hina and that naoto should
visit her alone as she does not know
that he saved her and they are now
strangers to each other as he walks away
takamichi says that telling hina to have
a good life is enough believing that
hina has forgotten all about him he
thinks about how he has changed the
future yet he has not changed at all as
he is still in the same circumstances as
the beginning he is still a 26 year old
virgin part-time loser believing that
hina has forgotten about him he thinks
about how he has changed the future yet
he has not changed as he is still in the
exact same circumstances as the
beginning as he prepares to return to
his life he bumps into a grown up hina
who remarks that he shows up at the
weirdest times takamichi cries upon
seeing her remembering the times that
she helped motivate him and he passed
driving him to change the future hina
nayoto and takamichi sit awkwardly in
heena's apartment despite their past
closeness unable to stand the
embarrassing atmosphere naoto begins to
leave but takamichi desperately begs him
to stay as he is extremely nervous he
now laughs at takamichi's reaction
remarking that he has not changed while
takamichi notices a four-leaf clover
heiner is wearing naoto decides to drive
the group elsewhere in an attempt to
lighten the atmosphere suddenly henya
orders naoto to stop his car when they
reach a park and she asks takamichi to
take a walk with her hina tells
takamechi that the park invokes memories
specifically a memory of her was someone
she liked on christmas eve hearing this
takamichi realises that hina has moved
on and laments about his naivety he
thinks back to when hina dumped him 12
years ago hina says that she has still
not forgotten the person that she was
with on christmas eve who broke up with
her takamichi replies that he cannot
believe that anyone would dump her and
hina crying wonders why she was dumbed
takamichi comes to the realization that
hina is talking about him overwhelmed
with this information he rushes to the
bathroom confused as his memories do not
align with this information as he walks
out of the bathroom he encounters a man
who remarks in surprise that takamichi
is not in the car though confused at
first upon seeing the man's hand tattoos
takamichi realizes that the man is hanma
and gets an uneasy feeling from this he
rushes to naoto's parked car where hina
is sitting just in time to see a car
driving towards it
as the car driving towards it smashes
into the back of naoto's parked car in
which heena was sitting in takamichi
horrified rushes towards the car the
driver of the car turns out to be an
extremely injured akun who asks
takamichi why he was not in the car the
same thing that hanma said while
takamichi and akona talking his car
lights up and explodes sending takamichi
flying back after this takamichi rushes
over tahina's car and finds her still
alive in it as takamichi attempts to get
hina out of the car to escape the
impending fire from the explosion she
thanks him takamitshi tells her that
they do not have time to talk as the car
will explode soon however hin has lost
all feeling in her legs due to the crash
crying takamichi crawls into the car
hugging hina and confessing that he has
and will always love her hina replies
that she is glad to hear him say that
and tells him to leave the car as she
does not want him to die with her which
takamichi refuses to do so feeling the
approaching fire hina pushes takamichi
away smiling at him before the car
explodes sending flames into the sky as
the fire rules in front of him takamichi
swears to save hina and find a future
where she is alive no matter how many
attempts it takes he resolves to become
the top member of tomen in order to do
this
later on october the 20th 2017 naoto
contacts takamichi and brings him to a
jail telling takamichi that draken is no
longer in towing but is not dead instead
he is on death row and they have come to
the jail to get information from draken
as he steps into the visitation booth
draken remarks that he has not seen
takamichi for a very long time and is
happy to see him doing well while
takamichi tears up upon seeing him
takamichi finds out that draken is on
death row because he committed murders
and asks dracon how this happened as
well as what happened to tomen draken
says he does not regret his actions and
that he knows he deserves to be in
prison as the current state of tomon is
because of him not stopping that guy
back in naoto's apartment takamichi is
still in belief about draken's status of
a murderer as he thinks back to the
meeting with draken and what draken
passionately said that he should have
killed kisaki and wonders what kind of
person kisaki is
naoto replies that kisaki currently
holds one of the most important
positions in tomen the acting leader he
believes that kisaki is responsible for
the repeated murders of hina but says
the police cannot find any leads to
kasaki after takamichi returns to the
past to find that kisaki has recently
joined the gang using parchin's absence
to become the division's new captain
moreover kesuki bashi is leaving to join
valhalla a gang with no known leader
after being recruited by kazutoro
hanamiya a former co-founder of the
tokyo magi gang
mikey promises takamichi that he will
remove kisaki from the gang if he is
able to bring back bhaji
with that takamichi is officially made a
member of the tokyo maji gang under
takashi matsuya's division takamichi
discovers that mikey holds a grudge
against kazutora for killing his older
brother shinachiro two years ago in
addition takamichi learns through
shifuyu matsuno that bhaji pretended to
defect from tomen to investigate kisaki
furthermore he learns that kisaki has
created valhalla for mikey to be its
leader and the tokyo magi gang will
eventually be absorbed into valhalla
after a rumble on the 31st of october
2005 known as bloody halloween their
loss had been caused by mikey killing
kazatura out of the rage of kazuthora
killing bhaji on october 31st the two
gangs finally meet at the junkyard a
bunch of prominent figures in the world
of delinquents show up and watch
valhalla and time and go head to head
the hashani brothers and the ikibukuro
criminal black members more well known
as just the icbm and a few other gangs
around the area
hansen a member of the icbm tries to
become an adjudicator for the fight
while discussing how the fight will go
on drakken pisses kazutura off by saying
that they'll take back bhaji kazatura
blows off steam by punching hanson when
he tried to calm him down as kazutura
lets out a threatening shout the two
gangs fly towards each other complete
chaos envelops the area as an all-out
brawl begins draken tries fighting
kazuzura but gets completely blocked off
by hanma because of this it meant that
maki and kazutora went into a face to
face and takamichi does his best to try
and stop them but is cut off like draken
by a valhalla member luckily though
matsuya shows up and saves him then
shifuyu tells takamichi that he has his
back and the other two fight against
several members of valhalla even
takamichi manages to land a few blows
but because of valhalla's sheer numbers
tomen's morale begins to collapse
takamichi screams at the top of his
lungs before falling and being caught by
matsuya the other tomen members look at
him dumbfounded and takamichi without
even noticing single-handedly increases
tomen's morale dracon then destroys a
group of valhalla's fodder members and
tries to get hanma to engage him as
mikey chases kasatura atop a mountain of
destroyed cars he gets ambushed by two
valhalla captains mikey tries to fend
off the captains but gets struck by a
middle pipe from behind kazutora
khazitora has chonbo and chong restrain
mikey while he hits him with the pipe
hanma declares the fight is over and
vrindo and hashani say that maki has
lost drakken rushes to help mikey but is
knocked down by hanma
meanwhile kazutoro declares that he will
kill the enemy referring to mikey in
order to become the hero in the midst of
kazatura's hits mikey asks if that is
the reason why kazutura killed
shinichiro breaking free from chonbo and
chome mikey instantly kicks kazutura
unconscious chombo chome and kazasora
are knocked out by mikey who falls to
his knees afterwards noticing mikey's
weaknesses choji prepares to lead
valhalla to curb stomp mikey takamichi
feels that he recognises choji but is
unable to put a finger on it shifuya and
mitsuya attempt to stop valhalla from
reaching mikey bar outnumbered meanwhile
draken continues to fight hanma
takamichi rushes towards maki in an
attempt to help him but is beat up by
various valhalla members just as choji
is about to strike maiki kisaki stands
between them knocking out choji with a
punch as kisaki declares that the first
division will protect maiki takamichi
remembers why he recognizes choji he
first saw him with kisaki the members of
tomin including matsuya and draken are
impressed with kisaki's loyalty and
skills takamichi realizes that no matter
the outcome of the battle kisaki will
achieve his goals he will be able to
rise within the ranks of tomon as draken
tells kisaki that he entrusts mikey to
him baji appears behind kisaki about to
strike him with a pipe baji successfully
knocks dakisaki to the delight of
valhalla members draken implores him to
stop and matsuya tells baji that they
came to bring him back bhaji is thrown
off by a toman member who asks kisaki if
he is all right kisaki calls baji a fly
and requests him to be swatted baji eggs
on kisaki and takamichi panics as he
believes baji will be killed if he
continues to fight suddenly shifuyu
appears in front of baji blocking his
path bhaji orders shifu to move out of
the way but he refuses telling bhaji
that taking down kisaki will make bhaji
face mikey in response baji hits shifuyu
with his pipe telling him that he only
kept him around to use him in fights so
he does not care about shifuyu shifuyu
tells baji that he wants to protect him
and if baji wants to get past him he
will not hold back baji tells shifu to
fight him in 10 seconds but shifuyu is
unable to move taunting him as he counts
down the seconds bhaji tells shifu that
killing him is the only way to stop him
just as baji reaches the end of his
count takamichi pushes baji out of the
way telling shifuyu to stop baji
together crying shifuyu tells takamiji
that he can't as he is unable to hit
bhaji someone he respects to get
takamichi to let go of him baji elbows
him in the head causing takamichi to
drift into unconsciousness until he
remembers his goals of saving hina and
mikey takamichi regains both his
consciousness and his resolve for a
better future starting with saving baji
from kisaki suddenly he remembers that
it is kazutora nakisaki who ends up
killing baji
searching for kasitora takamiji cannot
see him atop the pile of cars but
randomly kazutura appears behind bhaji
stabbing him after kazathora stabs baji
takamichi throws kazutora off him and
bhaji bhaji thanks takamichi for the
save and says that his stab wound is
just a scratch shifu grabs kazatora
questioning his motives while takamichi
tells baji that he's glad he is alive
baji tells him that he is taking down
kisaki regardless while takamichi
frantically ponders the situation from
kisaki saving maeki to baji attacking
kisaki and bhaji stabbing kazutora he's
confused by the situation and what to do
next but is relieved that bhaji is still
alive thereby eliminating mikey's reason
to kill kasatora leaving takamichi with
the goal of defeating kisaki and
becoming tomen's leader he and shifuyu
offer to fight kisaki along with bhaji
who responds to this by punching both of
them telling them to stay out of his way
when takamichi questions why baji is
doing this alone baji only responds by
telling takamichi to take care of mikey
forum 53rd division members stand
between kisaki and baji and baji begins
to fight them meanwhile kisaki observes
that kazutsura has failed and calls
hanma
baji eventually makes his way to kisaki
holding a sharp pipe to his neck
about to kill him baji suddenly
collapses to his knees coughing blood
from the injuries he has already
sustained rushing to his side shifuyu
demands to know what hisaki did to baji
tuwachikisaki responds that he did not
do anything
shifuyu notices the pool of blood and
bhaji and takamichi realizes that the
stab wound baji sustained was actually
severe ishifu screams kazatura's name
takamichi realizes that everything is
going along with kisaki's plans with
baji dying kisaki says that kazutsura
lured bhaji and to valhalla to kill him
which takamichi recognizes as a lie to
provoke mikey who gets up addressing
kazatura maiki tells him that bhaji was
the only one who stopped mikey from
killing casatora by explaining
kazutura's motives and rationale
takamichi notices mikey's lack of
emotion just as mikey declares that the
fight is over hanma protests this
challenging mikey but he is quickly
knocked unconscious by mikey's kirk upon
witnessing hanuman's defeat the rest of
valhalla run away fearing for their
lives kazutura tells mikey that he can
betray anyone and presents him with an
ultimatum to end their fight
either he or mikey has to die in
response mikey punches kazutora telling
him that if he destroys the things he
cares about he will have to destroy
kazutora as mahi continues beating
kasasura draken stays and no one will be
able to stop him thinking back to his
second prison visit to draken takamichi
realizes that the events are heading to
the bad future and cries upon knowing
that he is helpless on the phone hanuma
remarks that bhaji was a traitor after
all which causes kasatura to think that
bhaji is abandoning him as he thinks
back to the night he killed shinichiro
after kazutora swears to kill mikey baji
hugs him telling him not to say anything
so depressing as he will be with
kazuhura until the end as kasatura
realizes that he took what was precious
to himself and destroyed it he cries
saying that he will be with bhaji soon
despite his wounds baji rises and
screams for maiki he thanks mikey for
getting mad on his behalf and while
getting up and walking towards him says
that kazzatora's stab wound would not
kill him instead he opens his own
switchblade and stabs himself bhaji
tells kazutura that he will not be the
one to kill him shifuyu rushes to baji's
side asking why he did it while kasatur
arises and tells mikey he will die along
with bhaji mikey tells kazatura that he
will beat him to death takamichi asks
what baji wanted to achieve by stabbing
himself and bhaji tells takamichi that
kisaki is the enemy something he
realized when he witnessed kisaki
offering parchin's freedom in exchange
for the position as the third division
captain he does not consider kisahi the
third division captain saying that only
parchin will be the third division
captain baji says the six founding
members of tomen are his treasure and
although he was unable to fix tomen on
his own mikey has no reason to kill
kazatura now as baji died by his own
hands
nearing death bhaji tells takamichi that
he reminds him of shinochiro and says he
is leaving mikey and tomen and
takamichi's hands to watch takamichi
cries telling bhaji not to die bhaji
lies and shafu's arms telling him that
he would like to eat pay on yakisoba
with him as he cries shifuyu tells bhaji
he will buy some and baji tells him they
will split it thanking him with a smile
as he dies shifu screams in agony
angered by bhaji's death mikey begins
repeatedly punching kazasora to the
extent of knocking him unconscious as he
holds baji in his arms shifuyu tearfully
tells takamichi his frustrations and
being unable to save or help bhaji
takamishi also shares these feelings
reflecting upon his failed mission
suddenly he remembers bhaji's dying
words to him in which he entrusted the
fate of tomen to takamichi screaming
takamichi throws himself between mikey
and kazutora in an attempt to stop mikey
who threatens to kill takamichi as well
if he continues to interfere even after
getting punched by mikey takamichi
desperately implores him to stop saying
that bhaji would not have wanted this to
happen maki angrily tells takamichi not
to talk about bhaji which causes
takamichi to cry out in frustration
taking off his jacket takamichi explains
that bhaji died for tomen killing
himself so that kazatura would not be
responsible for his death and mikey
could forgive him as his jacket falls
baji's omamori charm falls out and mikey
asks takamichi where he got the charm
takamichi explains that he found it at
the altar after the third division
captain nomination the other founding
members including draken and matsuya
recognised the charm and are surprised
maki realizes that bhaji had held onto
the charm since tommen's founding
recalling their goal of a new age for
delinquents as he is shocked a glimmer
of light enters mikey's deep dark eyes
mikey reveals the origin of the charm
explaining that bhaji created tonemen
and its founding values takamichi
realises that bhaji was fighting to
uphold these ideals through his actions
while he tearfully apologizes to bhaji's
body for strain from these ideals as the
rest of tomen weeps the sound of police
signs approached the scene and both
gangs begin to leave the car lot however
kazutura decides to stay behind with
bhaji's body as a way to take
responsibility for his actions mikey
does not stop him from doing this but
just before he and the rest of time and
leave hazard bows in an apology although
he tells mikey that he does not expect
forgiveness for both shinichiro and
baji's deaths and he will carry the
weight of their deaths for the rest of
his life the october 31st conflict which
resulted in one death and one arrest
became known as bloody halloween toman
was considered the victor of this
conflict a few days later tomen gathered
for their next meeting taken michi
admits that he feels bashful and is
uniform while payan and mitsuya
encourage him when draken sees takamichi
he smiles telling him that his uniform
does not suit him at all and takamichi
agrees laughing that he feels like
somebody dressed him up dracon welcomes
takamichi into the gang again takamichi
passionately thanks him bowing and
dracon says that this meeting will begin
remarking that it will be an important
meeting for takamichi
appears on the stage with hanma and
shifuyu behind him draken remarks that
the meeting will be rough as it is
intended to conclude bloody halloween
seeing hanma the crowd wonders why a
valhalla member is there and takamachi
stares in confusion reviewing the events
of bloody halloween mikey announces that
hanma the leader of valhalla has a
message for tomin hanuma reveals that
valhalla never had an official leader
and because of this they will now join
under tomen hearing this announcement
tomen rejoices over its growth chanting
in celebration
watching the events unfold takamichi
realizes that nothing has changed much
as valhalla's affiliation with tomen is
essentially the same as the gang's
combining just then hanuma calls
fukasaki to step forward crediting him
with connecting the two gangs
remembering baji's words about kisaki
being the enemy takamichi shudders and
terror at the idea of kisaki taking over
tomen realising the events from bhaji's
death and kasatura's survival have been
for naught takamichi concludes that he
has failed once again after kasaki
oversees a handshake between hanuma and
mikey mikey announces an additional
topic to discuss maki sadly reflects on
the death of baji he turns to shifuyu
telling him to continue stepping forward
as the first division's vice-captain
shifuyu reveals that although he
considered leaving tomen after baji's
death maki stopped him asking him if he
wanted to thoroughly snuff out the first
division tu shifuyu leading the first
division is a great responsibility and
after consulting with mikey he's decided
to name a new first division leader
shouting from above shifuyu nominates
takamichi as the first division leader
he explains that this is what bhaji
would have wanted and mikey agrees
asking for a response maki tells
takamichi to raise his head thinking of
the futures that rely on him takamichi
realizes that he can still enact change
within tomen and amid his tears he
raises his head high loudly exclaiming
that he will do his best drachen asks
what he is crying about noting
takamichi's lack of discipline chuckling
matsuya remarks that he has to redo the
embroidery on takamichi's uniform and
mikey says that takamichi raised his
head too high after this takamichi meets
back up with naoto and decides to travel
back to the future where he finds
himself in the video store with his
manager standing across from him just as
he remarks their knowledge has changed
his manager bows in an apology to him
telling him that the video he requested
is out of stock rushing to the bathroom
takaminchi finds himself wearing a
designer watch bag and clothing with his
hair slipped back he is shocked by his
new appearance as he walks out of the
saw a scary man approaches him telling
takamichi he is late he orders takamichi
to get into a car confused and nervous
takamichi asks the man where they are
going and the man says that they are
going to takamichi's place just as he
ordered after he arrives at his location
takamichi realizes that he's been taken
to his new house which he lives in the
top floor of a high-rise apartment
complex when inside he finds shifuyu who
tells takamichi to answer his phone more
often in seeing shifuyu takamichi is
relieved to find a familiar face telling
him that he has no idea what's going on
shifuyu responds confused over
takamichi's lack of awareness and he
tells takamichi that he is a tomen
edmund mason revealing takamichi's
status as tomen's top admin much to his
shock while at the admin meeting hanma
comments on the dullness of the
situation and informs the group that
their meeting is not over routine
payments instead this meeting was held
to determine who betrayed tomen which
has led to the search of time and run
businesses by police as the former black
dragon members and the tomen captains
argue over who snitched kisaki enters
the room which compels all the admins to
bow as they greet him after the
tournament admins greet hisaki he
cheerfully tells them that all the
formalities are unnecessary as takamichi
notes that kisaki looks different
somehow hanuman mentions that kisaki
rarely shows up for admin meetings
hisaki asks to speak to takamichi and
shifuyu alone taking them into a
separate room after having a
conversation with each other whether
three discuss their past hates for each
other kisaki requests to have a drink
with them as the three of them toast to
baji's death 12 years earlier takamichi
thinks that kisaki has unexpectedly
changed into a better person wondering
if the current future is a good one
kisaki asks one more thing revealing
that his previous statements about
bhaji's death was a lie and he actually
used kazatura to kill baji kisaki tells
the shocked takamichi and shifuyu that
he intends to continue on from where
they left off takamichi's vision becomes
warp and he eventually blacks out when
he awakes takamichi is tied to a cheer
alongside shifuyu kysaki starts to
interrogate them and shifuyu ends up
saying that he was an informant for the
police and this was his form of revenge
for bhaji's death kisaki continues to
repeatedly kick shifuyu who tells kisaki
that he wanted to get him out of tomin
which he believes has turned into a
warped organization shifuyu confesses
that he is the snitch while maintaining
that takamichi was not involved in
response kisaki says that he is not the
one that determines if takamichi was
involved or not before shooting
takamichi near thigh or why he has been
acting like he is not involved with this
situation as takamishi screams in pain
shifuyu desperately repeats that
takamichi was not involved telling shifu
to shut up kisaki prepares to kill him
and asks him if he has any last words
shifuyu addresses his last words to
takamichi he tells him that a lot has
happened over the last 12 years
including mahi's death disappearance
dracon's death penalty and his own
involvement in crime however shifuyu
says that deep down they have not
changed he tells takamichi that he
leaves the words of bhaji and the future
of thailand to takamichi hisaki then
shoots shifuyu in the head mocking his
words
as he prepares to kill takamichi
takamichi cries at witnessing shifuyu's
death kyusaki yells at takamichi for
crying and his impending death and weeps
as he holds the gun to his head calling
him a hero just before kisaki shoots
takamichi the room goes dark antakamishi
is carried out before he falls back into
unconsciousness he wakes up near an
underpass with his gunshot wound wrapped
up in front of him a man with long
flowing hair stands up who he mistakes
for bhaji at first however the man turns
out to be kazutora who has been released
from prison
suddenly kazatura punches and kicks
takamichi then tells him that he
witnessed a woman being based on the
street similar to what he just did to
takamichi he reveals that the men who
were beating up the woman were members
of tomen leading him to contemplate what
kind of organization tomen has become
kazatura pulls into an alleyway and
tells takamechi that someone wants to
meet him there takamichi is relieved and
delighted to find naoto unbeknownst to
kazutura and takamichi naoto set this up
in order to arrest takamichi in an
interrogation room naoto shows takamichi
a video secretly recorded by shifuyu
naoto tells takamichi that his actions
in the past dramatically changed the
future and he and takamichi have not
spoken since middle school takamichi is
a top admin in tauman and hina was
killed when akun crashed his car into
hers shifuyu and naoto had worked
together to avenge hina's death as he
watches the video naruto tells takamichi
he had no choice but to arrest him in
the video takamichi orders akun to carry
out an assassination as ordered by
kisaki although he does not know the
identity of the target in another
secretly recorded video takamichi has a
meltdown upon learning that the
assassination target was hina nayoto
says that although their videos show
proof of kisaki's involvement in heinous
shifuyu kept the videos hidden in an
attempt to protect takamichi
in shock takamichi falls to his knees
blaming himself for the death of hina
akun and shifuyu he cries about his
uselessness and saving the future and
wants to give up
however naoto hugs him telling takamichi
that he is not useless he helps shape
tomen into the organization it is now
through the influence of draken shifuyu
kazutora and baji naoto urges takamichi
to change the world as he believes he is
the only one who can fix the future
naoto tells takamitshi that he believes
kisaki is obsessed with hina since he
gets her killed in every future suddenly
there is a knock on the door of the
interrogation room naosu tells takamichi
they do not have much time as takabichi
is about to be moved into a detention
center making their meetings difficult
they decide to shake hands as naoto
tells takamichi that he must find what
happened between him and kisaki as he
time leaps takamichi thinks of those he
has determined as enemies the black
dragons and kisaki he swears to remove
them from tomen and save those he cares
about
after he arrives back in the past
takamichi is with hakai as they approach
the sheba household yuzuha remarks that
they might be in trouble as their
brother is coming back home all of a
sudden in front of them numerous members
of the black dragons gang stand yuzaha
urges takamichi to leave with hina and
as they are about to leave taiju
suddenly appears behind them lunging at
takamichi knocking him to the ground
taiju continues to beat up takamichi
then asks who he is he learns of
takamichi status as tomen's first
division captain and laughs in disbelief
that hakai brought a member of toman to
their home while hakai begs for his
brother to show mercy towards takamichi
takamichi notes that hekai's mentality
has changed in the presence of his
brother taiju tells hikai that their
relationship as brothers takes priority
over the relationships within tomen
causing yuzah to confront taiju telling
him not to corner hakai in response taju
punches her blaming her lack of
discipline towards hakai and warning her
that he will deal with her later to get
his brother to stop hakai is forced to
say that he will quit tomin and join the
black dragons when takamichi awakes from
unconsciousness he has been carried on
hakai's back with hina at his side
takamichi apologizes for forcing hakai
to leave tomen but hakai says that he
had already decided to leave a while ago
takamishi suddenly remembers what the
future kazutora told him about hakai and
how he would kill his older brother for
money then take over the black dragons
lion and beard takamichi begins to piece
together what will happen hakai will
kill taiju and merge the black dragons
with tomen resulting in the bad future
he saw
however he does not think that he has to
stop hakai from killing taiju as he
concludes that the black dragons will be
a threat regardless of the leader
takamichi suspects that shifuyu will
tell him not not to deal with the
conflict alone but shifuyu simply tells
him to have fun as baji did not leave
tomon to him in order to bring stress
into takamichi's life abruptly takamichi
confesses that he came from the future
shifu asks takamichi what he means by
saying he is from the future overwhelmed
by his burden takamichi tells shifuyu
everything that has happened to him thus
far including how shifuyu sacrificed
himself for takamuchi shifuyu believes
takamichi telling him that somehow he
always knew the truth like sometimes
takamichi looks different and somehow he
knew that baji was going to die during
the bloody halloween incident
although takamichi feels powerless in
his failures shifuyu tells him that he
is incredible later shifu says the
thought of getting killed by kisaki
along with the premeditation of bhaji's
death angers him enough to kill kisaki
however takamichi and shifuyu know they
are weak compared to kisaki's third
division which has over a hundred men as
well as the new sixth division which is
made up of valhalla members and hanma
two days later the leaders of tomen have
a
at the tourman meeting draken says that
taiju's attack on takamichi acts as a
declaration of war by the black dragons
hikai tells the group that he expects
punishment for his brother's actions and
requests to leave tauman as takamichi
frantically thinks about what to do
draken asks mikey what his decision is
mikey replies that he will allow matsuya
to decide since hakai belongs in
mitsuya's division as takamichi
witnesses what he sees as another
failure to change the future
matsuya tells hakai that he did not
permit him to leave and asks to talk to
taiju hakai tries to dissuade mitsuya
from meeting with taiju to which mitsuya
reassures him telling hikai that he
always tries to handle these issues
alone
at taiji's place he accused mitsuya of
negatively influencing hakai and
threatens to kill him matsuya tells
taiju that he will not see hakai again
allowing him to join the black dragons
on one condition taiju must stop his
domestic violence against yuzah and
mitsuya believes that hikai is joining
the black dragons to protect yuzah in
response tajiu punches mitsuya who
brushes off the assault he repeats his
conditions to taiju and taiju ends up
agreeing telling matsuya that he will
not hit yuzuha again takamichi and
shifuyu reflect on what just happened as
their goal of preventing hakai from
leaving tomond failed however takamichi
now believes that hakai will kill taiju
to protect yu zahar hakai approaches
them and asks to thanks matsuya for him
when takamichi asks why hakai says that
his home life is complicated and says
that he and his siblings grew up without
the presence of either parent which put
taiju in charge akai says that he has
sworn to protect his family ever since
matsuya told him that violence should be
used to protect others from then on
hakai has been taking beatings for yuzah
in addition to his own however taiju
beat yuzah regardless
hakai explains the agreement taiji made
with mitsuya will likely have no value
to him and he will continue to hurt
yuzuha when takamichi asks what they can
do to help hakai confesses that he is
terrified and powerless when facing his
brother he says that things would be
better if taiji was not around and that
he does not want to give tomen a bad
name so he left the gang to pursue his
intentions to kill taiju as he leaves
them hakai says that the short time they
spent together was fun takamichi tells
shifuyu that hikai's situation angers
him as it gives him little choice but to
kill his brother takamichi and shifuyu
pledge to defeat the black dragons and
create a better future as a cafe
takamichi and shifuyu tell the other
captains of their desire to fight the
black dragons draken smiley and mucho
firmly reject this as it would break
matsuya's agreement and ruin his
reputation taken means she decides that
he and shifuyu will deal with the issue
on their own
suddenly hisaki offers to help takamachi
and shifu and their goal to stop hakai's
plan to kill taiju kisaki says that they
do not have another choice as they would
easily be overpowered by the black
dragons without the support of the other
divisions kisaki says that he wants to
stop the black dragons from gaining more
power angered by kisaki's disrespect
towards mikey shifuyu holds a shard of
broken glass to kisaki's neck telling
him not to act superior in response
hanuma holds a knife to takamichi's neck
reminding shifuyu that infringing is
prohibited to convince shifuyu kisaki
reveals that there is a mole within the
black dragons they pay a hundred
thousand yen to the mole who is feared
of getting core kasaki reassures him
that no one will turn on him just as he
is beginning to tell them koko bursts
into the room declaring that he smells a
rat spotting the hundred thousand on the
table coco says that he will tell them
what they want to know if he is given
that money kisaki requests to know when
taiji was alone koko says that tajiu is
never alone as he is always guarded with
five soldiers save for a single day
christmas day when takamichi asks why
koko is betraying taiju he says that he
just likes strong guys kisaki tells
takamichi that he did not want to know
when taiji was alone to kill him instead
he suspects that this is when hakai will
try to kill taiju hisaki tells takamichi
that he wants to know by tomorrow
whether or not they will work together
shifuyu is opposed to working with
kisaki due to his hatred but takamichi
hopes to use the opportunity to find
information on kisaki he and takamichi
find them to let them know but make sure
to emphasize that their collaboration is
only to further their goals as they
dislike each other as takamichi walks
home a man approaches him introducing
himself as heena and naoto's father
masato tajibana sitting down at the
restaurant masato tells takamichi that
his wife has told him a lot about him
such as him dating hina takamichi is
visibly nervous in front of heena's
father but masato reassures him telling
takamechi that he does not need to be
nervous up until recently naoto hated
his father's job as it kept them apart
but now he wants to become a police
officer masato attributes this change to
takamechi and thanks him sincerely
bowing he then asks takamichi to do a
favour for him takamichi sits alone in
the restaurant processing the favour
masato asked him the favor that masato
asked was that he wants takamichi to
break up with hina due to the status of
takamichi being a delinquent on
christmas eve takamichi is late as he
told shifu that he has something small
to take care of quickly he meets up at
umashita park with hina and tells her
that they should break up saying that he
found another girl and does not love her
anymore in response hina punches him
telling takamichi that he is a jerk as
takamichi lies in the snow he convinces
himself that he's made the right
decision since it could keep hina from
kisaki's violence takamichi arrives at
the cafe where kisaki hanma and shifuyu
are waiting hama ridicules takamichi's
swollen eyes and kisaki lays out the
plan for the next day he speculates that
hakai will attack taichu in the church
so they will wait for taiji outside the
chapel takamichi is given the role of
reasoning with akai while the rest of
the group will beat down taiju outside
although he does not know what takamichi
did before the meeting shifuhu tells him
to use his anger to motivate himself
tomorrow on christmas day hakai puts on
his black dragon's uniform and promises
to settle everything meanwhile tajiu
leaves the black dragons in the
temporary command of koku and inyupay as
he prepares to observe his annual
christmas ritual of going to church
alone
shifuyu approaches takamichi and bows
telling takamichi how baji impacted his
life he then presents baji's ceremonial
sash to takamichi who promises to honour
bhaji's legacy by facing obstacles head
on just like how bhaji did with all four
of them were in their uniforms complete
with their sashes they approached the
church takamichi reminds himself that
they have to fight this battle alone
without depending on tomen right before
he enters the church shifuyu reassures
takamichi telling him that persuading
hikai is the most important aspect of
the plan entering the church takamichi
finds sakai standing in front of the
altar
he calls them out and hakai turns around
asking takamichi why he is here
takamichi replies that he is here to
stop hakai's plan to kill taiju just
then taju enters the church reciting a
prayer upon seeing him takamichi wonders
what happened to kasaki and the others
who were supposed to defeat taiju
irritated todd you demand to know why
they are in the church when justice taji
stays there hikaya lunges adam with the
knife screaming in one of the church's
rooms hanuma restrains shifuyu remarking
that he put up a good fight wakisaki
watches meanwhile tajiu easily stops
akai's attack and begins strangling him
telling hikai that he only acts tough
and admonishing him for failing to kill
him telling him not to yell instead
hakai should have quietly stabbed him
from behind taiju taunts akai telling
him that his back is open to stab only
using half of his power taji punches
takamichi causing him to lose
consciousness as takamiji struggles to
come back too he is terrified by taiju's
power believing that he may even be
killed meanwhile taiju continues to
haunt hakai who cannot do anything out
of fear he tells hakai that he plans to
kill takamichi as he strangles takamichi
taju asks if he knows why hakai wants to
kill him takamichi responds that it is
because of taiju's abuse towards yusuha
which causes taiju to laugh and taunt
hakkai he threatens to reveal hakai's
secret telling takamichi that hikai is
not the sort of person he thinks he is
before taiju can continue yuzuha appears
behind him with a knife shocked
takamishi calls her out just before she
stabs taichu in the back in response
taja releases takamichi and punches
yuzuha throwing her across the church
hakai angrily accuses takamichi of
telling yuzah his plans as only
takamichi knows however yuzah reveals
that kosaki told her everything
intentionally takamichi wonders if
kisaki goaded yusuha into killing taiju
and the future rumors about hakai
killing his brother were false
reflecting on this takamichi realizes
that yuzuha killed taiju in the original
timeline just then taiju takes off his
coat revealing that the stab wound is
shallow a tribute team tokuminshi's
shout to helping him to avoid a severe
wound seeing this takamishi realizes
that he saved taiju wondering if he
avoided the future in which kisaki
manipulates hikai taiji abuses sakai and
yuzah for trying to kill him their
brother he tells them that he has done a
lot for their sake which use a hard
dispute telling taiju that he did it all
for himself taiju punches yuzuha once
again throwing her against the altar
allowed taju questions why god puts him
through ordeals such as being forced to
murder his own sister taiju tells yuzah
that he will kill her when she charges
at him taiju punches her and says that
he will slowly beat her to death putting
himself between them takamichi tells
tajiu to calm down and says that he is
the one tearing his family apart while
believing that he cares about them
takamichi tells akai to protect his
sister and asks what he is so scared of
just then taju punches takamichi and
throws another pew at him saying that
his siblings were the ones trying to
hurt him in the first place takamichi
narrowly avoids the pew as well and
exclaims that trying to kill each other
does not make sense
standing up yuzaha tells him that it is
the path all of them chose thinking back
to how hakai has been protecting yuzah
takamichi determines that yuzuha is the
key to the events she killed taiju in
the original timeline after being
instigated by kisaki the hakai took
responsibility as the killer using this
knowledge hisaki was able to manipulate
hikai who assumed the leadership of the
black dragons leading to the corruption
of tomen takamichi declares he has to
beat down taiju believing that
protecting yuzah will stop the
corruption of tomen hakai tells him that
he does not know the full extent of
taju's violence grabbing her knife yuzah
tells takamichi not to get in her way as
she will protect hakai suddenly mitsuya
appears grabbing yuzah's blade as he
tells her to let go of the knife saju
asks what happened to their agreement
and taunts matsuya for breaking it
matsuya says that he will tell tajiu
something more important even if she
misbehaves he should never hurt his
little sister instead she should be
forgiven with a smile which is what
being an older brother is about
outside on a cb250t
mikey asks strakken if he heard
mitsuya's bike shivering draken tells
mikey that he is hearing things as no
one would be stupid enough to ride a
bike in the cold weather meanwhile
matsuya and taiju fight watakamichi
noting that matsuya can match taiju's
strength suddenly matsuya takes her knee
and taji taunts him to the relief of
hakai takamichi and shifuyu matsuya was
just tightening a strap on his boot as
they continue to fight akai tells
matsuya to stop a pointless battle as he
believes that he cannot win against
taiju's strength anupai appears behind
metsuya and swings a pipe at his head
which causes him to collapse
azakai screams for mitsuya koko enters
and asks the group if his information
was worth one hundred thousand much to
hikai's horror matsuya is motionless on
the ground shifuyu and takamichi prepare
to fight taiju koko and anupay justice
takamichi and shifuyu charge it taiju
matsuya gets up and tells them to calm
down as he is alright however he still
sways from the impact of the pipe
sitting down matsuya acknowledges the
direness of the situation taiju koko and
inyupay are all strong while he and
shifu are already all beat up leaving
takamachi as the only one able to fight
however matsuya says that if they lose
yuzuha may even get killed takamichi
tells matsuya not to worry as mikey and
the others will come to help so all they
have to do is stall for time until they
arrive matsuya asks takamichi if he
called mikey which confuses him as
takamichi had thought that matsuya would
have called mikey matsuya responds that
he came here alone to help hakai as an
issue unrelated to tomen he says that
the three of them alone will have to
protect yuzah
overwhelmed takamichi falls to his knees
he believes that there is no possible
way that they can win against the black
dragons and that they will all be killed
matsuya tells hakai that he is under no
obligation to help since he is a black
dragon member however he asks hakai to
help him to protect yuzah asakai's
stammers matsuya says he understands how
fearful he is of taiju takamichi screams
to motivate himself and he and shifuyu
prepare to fight shifuyu will take on
inyupay and takamichi will take on coco
because koko is willing to sell
information about taiju he might be
willing to stop the fight if taiji was
significantly weakened with shifuyu
already worn out from his fight with
hanuma and takamichi's limited fighting
skills they struggle to hold back in
yupe and koko takaminchi says that he
cannot hold off coco for much longer and
koko notes that they are stalling for
time until matsuya and hikai can defeat
taiju as matsuya rushes towards taichu
taiji begins laughing turning around
matsuya sees that hikai has not moved
trembling hakai apologizes to matsuya
for his lack of resolve tarju asks what
matsuya was expecting from a person like
kakai then punches him just then
takamichi is kneed by koko and shifuyu
collapses on the floor grabbing his
knife and rushing towards taiju hakai
tries to gain the resolve to kill taiju
still coughing and panting from the
impact of koko's attack takamichi puts
himself between hakai and taiju grasping
hikai's blade takamichi tells him that
he will become an irredeemable person if
he follows through with the act as
murdering someone is no way to fight
back telling hikai that he will show
what it means to fight back takamichi
prepares to face taiju who remarks that
takamichi has not learned his past
lesson even after being attacked by
taiju numerous times tatu easily
counters takamishi's attacks with a
punch to his face by the time taju asks
how many times he has to punch takamichi
until he gives up takamichi's face is
swollen and bloodied but he refuses to
lose seeing takamichi's wounded face
shifuyu weeps telling him to stop and
accept defeat takamichi grasps the
necklace that haina gave him asking for
courage he concludes that as long as
taiju and the black dragons exist hakai
will be unable to stand up for himself
takamichi tells taiju that he will
defeat him and take control of the black
dragons in response tatu punches him
once more but takameki declares that he
is not done yet shifuyu implores
takamichi to stop fighting taiju telling
him that he will die if he continues
takamichi believes that the future may
not necessarily change if he continues
fighting but if there's a small chance
of that happening he will continue to
risk his life just then he and taiju
simultaneously punch each other in the
face and takamichi is thrown back by the
force while tatu remarks that
takamichi's punch did not even hurt
however to taiju's shock he falls onto
his knees as takamichi unsteadily gets
back up hakai begs him to stop with a
beason and bloody face he tells akai
that fighting on is not painful what
hurts him more than anything is
loneliness as inyape koko yuzaha mitsuya
and shifuyu react in shock when
takamichi compels taiji to his knees
takamichi tells zakai that he will
protect yuzah for him hikai tells
takamichi that he is wrong as his own
face does not have a bruise while yusuha
is injured
although his encounter with mitsuya made
him want to protect his family he did
not have the courage to stand up to
taiju he confesses that he lied to
takamichi about his circumstances
instead of him protecting yusaha from
taiju it was yuzaha who tried to protect
him from taking twice the amount of
beatings hakai apologizes to takamichi
for involving him in this situation
through his fear in response takamichi
tells zakai that he sucks for his
actions but he says that he sucks more
himself referring to his past cowardice
and their lack of resolve standing up
matsuya also tells akai that he sucks
but says that he was hypocritical for
telling hakai not to hate the situation
he was born into when he hated his own
takamishi says that his true family will
not abandon him because of a lie as this
is what thaiman should be about as
shifuyu mitsu and takamichi watchikai
tell taiju that he will beat him down to
protect his family shifuyu observes that
hikai has changed instead of deciding to
kill taiju hakai has decided to beat him
down shifuyu tells takamichi that the
future will change meanwhile taju asks
aloud why god continues to test him by
compelling him to kill both of his
siblings with a swift punch taju knocks
hakai unconscious tatu tells shifuyu
matsuya and takamichi that they will
have to die as well as there are 100
black dragon members outside blocking
them from escape looking out their
window shifuyu confirms this takamishi
tells shifu that they do not intend to
run away as the future will not change
until they defeat taji and the black
dragons as yuzah watches the others
fighting the black dragons for the sake
of akai she realizes that she is not
alone shifuyu having fought inupay falls
to the ground with an injured leg while
mitsuya fighting coco takes a knee from
his exhaustion takamichi staggers from
his injuries and taiju tells hikai that
he is an idiot as he will end up losing
everything hakai tells him to shut up
and learn his lesson and hell
just then hikai remarks that he is
starting to hear things however it is
not just a hallucination but the sound
of mikey's cb250t
approaching from the distance as taiju
koko and inyupay wonder why maki is here
takamichi exclaims with relief that they
can now defeat the black dragons with
mikey's aid mikey enters the church and
wishes everyone a merry christmas
smiling he asks what they are all doing
mikey says that his older brother
recognized the impulse sound of
mitsuya's bike and baji said that only
matsuya's bike sounded that nice and the
two of them led mikey to the church
takamichi and mitsuya are concerned as
both shinichiro and baji are dead when
tajiu approaches maiki mahi asks why
he's standing in his way as he just
wants to ride with his friends
taiju punches mikey in the face and
knocks him unconscious
as the church bells chime kaiju declares
his victory against the so-called
invincible mikey angered by this matsuya
lunges at taiju but just then maki rises
behind a shock taiju telling him that
prayer time is now over taiju tells mahi
that his punch was the best that he had
thrown all day additionally matsuya and
takamichi are unnerved by mikey's
strange behavior as he referenced
shinichiro and bhaji as if they were
still alive as takamichi wonders if mahi
will be defeated mikey responds that the
punch he took from taiju was just
punishing himself before he can
comprehend what happened kaiju was lying
unconscious at mikey's feet
to the shock and awe of everyone there
mikey flies through the air and knocks
taiji unconscious maki says that he
decided to go out riding with baji and
shitachiro every christmas
and takamishi is concerned about making
his mental state until mikey takes out
bhaji's omamori charm explaining that
when he rides with his brother's bike
and baji's charm it's like they are
still there with him hearing this
takamishi is sure that mikey will not
turn evil mikey prepares to leave the
church telling them to go on a ride but
taiju held up by any pay tries to
prevent them from leaving he orders koko
to bring in the black dragons members
from outside saying that he refuses to
lose to anyone
crawling to the entrance of the church
taiju finds dracon waiting outside on
his steps with all the black dragons
members defeated on the ground even
though they are already worn out from
their previous fights takamichi shifuyu
matsuya and akai prepare to fight the
100 black dragons members outside of the
church
just then draken enters the church and
asks why everyone is so tense as he
informs mikey that he has defeated all
of the black dragons waiting outside
with taiju's will to fight gone and the
black dragons defeated tomen has
effectively ended the black dragons
rushing out of the church yuzuha shifuyu
and matsuya marvel at drakon's strength
takamichi cries in relief when he notes
that everyone has survived telling
shifuyu that his mission is complete as
he faints from exhaustion everyone
agrees that the role takaminchi played
in the knights events was of the utmost
importance before leaving hakai and
yuzah speak to their brother
hakai asks a silent taijo how his first
ever loss fell he tells taiju that he is
strong and will recover shortly but he
and yuzuha will never give in to taiju's
abuse again after this takamichi asks
what they are doing at heine's home and
mikey doesn't provide a helpful response
as heena stands before him takamichi
feels awkward and does not know what to
say as the way he dumped her was
completely one-sided seeing tokumichi's
swollen and bloody face heena simply
asks if he got into another fight
takamichi begins to tear up and bursts
into tears apologizing to hina although
he understands where her father is
coming from he tells her that he cannot
let her get her after he swore to save
her which confuses hina even if she gets
run over by a truck and becomes
paralyzed he says he will save her no
matter how many tries it takes takamichi
tearfully asks if they can get back
together hina tells takamichi to take
her to the shrine on new years and tells
them that they have made up takamichi
touched by the moment begins to cry
after they leave heena's maiki tells
takamichi that sometimes he does not
know what is going on his brother should
be alive but he is not and he does not
understand what this means during this
time mikey says that he becomes
disorientated and unable to tell the
difference between right and wrong
takamichi realizes that mikey is
self-aware of the darkness inside him
and the potential of that darkness to
take hold of him mikey tells takameshi
that his brother sparkled brighter than
anything when he led his gang the
members were sure they would not lose as
they could rely on shinichiro takamichi
says that mikey is just like his brother
but mikey says that he is just weak
while takamichi is strong maki asks
takamichi to scold him like his brother
would if he loses control of himself
takamichi promises that he will
meanwhile as they look over the city
hanuma remarks that he never expected
takamichi to pull off what happened on
christmas night however kisaki says it
will not end here
drakken announces the beginning of
tommen's first meeting of the year he
and mikey informed tomin of the conflict
with taiju and the black dragons through
the testimony of three people called to
the front hakai takes responsibility for
the conflict as it all started with a
lie he told the second person called up
is inupi who was with koko nui because
the 10th generation black dragons lost
to tomen and taji retired they are now
the leaders of the 11th generation after
talking with mikey they have decided to
join under tomen mikey assigns them to
the first division under takamichi's
command much to everyone's shock when
takamichi asks what the reasoning behind
the decision was mikey says that both
inyupay and koko wanted to be under his
command the last person mikey calls up
is kisaki regarding his involvement in
the christmas conflict mikey tells
kisaki that he is fired
a shock kisaki asks maki if he is joking
but mikey says he is not approaching the
stage hanuma says that if mikey is fired
then he will leave as well maki says
that he does not care as tomin has
gotten too big in response kisaki
reminds mikey that expanding tomen is
his goal to which mikey asks if kisaki's
instigation of the christmas conflict
was a way to expand tomin shifuyu
reiterates that he did not think kisaki
would be fired as he and mitsuya did not
have concrete evidence of kisaki's
betrayal a panicked kisaki runs towards
mikey telling him that he has grown weak
as taji posed a threat to tomen so he
acted for mikey's sake draken appears in
front of kisaki asking who allowed him
to come near mikey hanma swings at
draken telling him to let kisaki tour
watching this takamichi wonders if
kasaki is desperate as he can no longer
achieve his goal of becoming mikey's
right-hand man mikey upholds his
decision telling hisaki that his
arbitrary actions will ruin his dream
later on they reveal a cb250 bike to
takamachi which maki remarks is the same
bike as his he says his brother found
two engines for the bike in the
philippines where they were lying
abandoned mikey says that someday he
wants to go to the place where his
brother found the engines and takamichi
agrees after his time leap takamichi
finds himself at a shrine meaning that
he was able to change the future as he
wonders if hina has been saved a woman
approaches him remarking that it's been
an extremely long time since they last
saw each other takamichi discerns that
he is at a funeral but does not know
whose from the conversation between two
of the deceased sisters a shocked
takamichi realises the funeral is for
mitsuya
entering the temple he is horrified to
find a picture of mitsuya surrounded by
flowers when he checks his phone he
finds that matsuya's death is suspected
to be a murder additionally hina was
killed dying in exactly the same way as
before
entering his apartment he finds it as
familiar as ever as he wonders how the
events transpired takamichi notices the
final photo he took with mikey and the
others just then naoto enters the
apartment telling takamichi that he has
been looking for him as his memory was
overwritten naoto says that this is the
worst future that has occurred thus far
shifuyu was shot to death hakai was
burned to death matsuya was strangled to
death and dracon was stabbed to death
additionally other chief members of
tomen were murdered as well including
kazatora parchin and even kisaki naoto
reveals that maki is the one who
perpetrated all of the murders a shocked
takamichi insists that mikey would never
kill anyone and naoto says that he wants
to know the truth as well naoto asks if
takamichi would know anything about this
as he could have gained information from
the past and also asks where takamichi
found the photo and takomichi responds
that he found it on top of the table
they found a letter from the philippines
on the table sent from mikey after
reading the letter and deducing where
maki is takamichi and naoto arrive in
manila and the philippines mikey's
leader asked him to meet at the place he
told takamichi about where his brother
found the two bike engines eventually
takamichi finds a pile of old bike parts
which was the location mikey told him
about
behind him mikey calls his name turning
around takamichi sees that mikey has the
same look in his eyes as he did 12 years
ago mikey says that tomen has changed
he asks takamichi why he left homan as
he wanted takamichi to stay with him
reminding takamichi of his request to be
scolded as his brother would have if he
stepped out of line mikey recalls him
trying to stop takamichi from leaving
tarman but both drakken and matsuya
believe that takamichi should go
throwing a gun at takamichi's feet mikey
requests a tfo takamichi to kill him a
confused takamichi tells him to stop as
he only wanted to see mikey again mikey
tells takamichi that it was difficult to
achieve his goals but when he killed
someone for the first time he felt
nothing instead he found killing as an
easy solution to most of the world's
problems shaking him takamichi tells
mikey that he can tell that he has not
changed from 12 years ago
mikey tells him to stop and slams
takamichi onto the ground pressing a gun
to his cheek as he cries he tells
takamichi that they can not bring back
the past and a shot rings out now so
shoots mike in the head he then cautions
takamichi to stay away from mikey just
in case naosu then notices the safety on
mikey's gun was on
meaning that he never intended to kill
takamichi in the first place mikey
thanks naoto for shooting him as he says
that takamichi probably could not have
before he dies he remarks that
takamichi's hand is warm
crying takamichi remembers the many
moments they shared together from when
they first met to when mikey told him
that he was strong holding mikey's body
and his arms a determined lock flashes
across takamichi's face
later on in a flashback emma's mother
tells her that she has to go somewhere
far away and leaves emma at her
grandfather's house this was the last
time emma ever saw her mother
as emma watches her grandfather's
martial arts class shinochiro walks by
and compliments bhaji on his fighting
skills bhaji says that emma sounds like
a foreigner's name which maki agrees
bhaji then dubs himself as ed short for
edward to match emma's foreign name and
mikey sano at the time dubs himself
mikey short for michael they run around
the dojo playing and joking around in
the midst of this emma admits allowed
that she knows her mother hates her as
it is why she abandoned her even though
she knows this she cannot stop herself
from missing her in the present emma
reflects that she has never felt lonely
from that time on smiling she walks
towards draken who has been waiting for
her outside somewhere else takuya
remarks that he has to use the restroom
as his stomach hurts akun says that he
has to go as well
just as yamagishi tells shifuyu that
they got jumped by another gang these
same gang members exit a train in front
of takamichi bringing out a basin akun
they ask him if takamichi is a tarman
member as well
one of the gang members tells takamichi
that he will become the fifth time and
victim before he can begin his assault
shifuyu runs up and kicks him saving
takamichi he tells tokomichi to run
before long shifuyu is knocked out by a
gang member who declares that there was
slaughter tomen when akun regains
consciousness he reveals that there are
300 tenjuku members in tokyo takomichi
realises shifuyu will be in trouble he
tells akun and the others to go to
tomen's hideout while he goes to help
shifuyu as he runs hoping for shifuy's
safety he is ambushed by tenjuku
suddenly akun appears kicking one of
takamichi's attackers
in surprise takamichi realizes that akun
yamagashi and makoto followed him they
tell takamichi that they will help him
as he is their captain though they fight
earnestly they are outnumbered and
overpowered atenjiku member acclaims
their victory as he lies on the ground
exhausted takamichi wonders about the
motive and origin of tenjuku as he has
never heard or encountered them before
from the crowd of tenjuku members kisaki
steps forward approaching takamichi he
speculates that takamichi has no idea
what's going on and announces that the
beginning of the kanto uprising is
beginning kisaki announces to takamichi
that he is now the general staff officer
of tenjuku a yokohama gang as the
tenjuku members surround takamichi and
his friends two bikes suddenly arrive
mowing down the panicked group on one of
the bikes someone hutakumichi recognizes
as smiley the fourth division captain
arrives with an unconscious dakuya
takamichi is confused until smiley pulls
him up onto the bike yamageshi explains
that smiley has a twin nicknamed angry
who is the vice captain of the fourth
division the twins take shifuyu and
takamichi to raid yokohama to
counter-attack tenjiku after they
noticed two tenjiku members smiley and
angry prepare to gather information
about tenjuku's hideout from them
takamichi remarks that their method of
gathering information is more like
torture takamichi tells shifuyu that he
meet kasaki who joined tenjiku and he
now believes that kisaki's goal is to
create a tourman that is convenient for
him coming from the future to achieve
his goal if kisaki is a time leaper he
is now desperate as he was killed by
mikey in the future and can no longer
return until he can change the future
however shifu says that they have to
find out if kisaki is truly a time
leaper takamichi shifuyu smiley and
angry find tenjiku's hideout in a
warehouse where a great number of
tenjuku members are waiting for them
they realize that they have been led
into a trap a tensioku member steps
forward indicating that they have been
waiting when takamichi asks the leader
of the group how many tenjuku members
they are facing he replies that there
are a hundred unexpectedly he orders all
of them to leave the tenjiku member
introduces himself as kakucho one of
tenjiku's big four and smiley swings a
punch just before smiley gains the upper
hand kokuto grins smiley knocks down
kokucho by diving at him with his legs
outstretched as kokucho lies on the
ground smiley tells him that he is as
strong as he expected taiju's big four
to be as the group prepares to go back
to tokyo takamichi says that kokucho
seems familiar takamichi realises that
kokucho was his elementary school friend
takumeji tells kokucho he has not
changed at all and still picks fights
when which kikuchi responds that
takumichi has not changed either calling
him his hero he tells takamichi that he
has devoted himself to izana kudokawa
now tenjiku's boss in essence he is now
enemies with takamichi later at tommen's
emergency meeting takamichi continues to
ponder kisaki's role draken announces
the commencement of the meeting tomin
members were attacked in various parts
of tokyo all by tenjiku members the
first division is called up to explain
their experience with shifuyu explaining
that the group who attacked them was
called team mochizuki mitsuya disputes
mochi's role as tenjuku's main force
telling them that the hatani brothers
were also part of tenjiku draken adds
that the other tomen members were also
attacked by shion madarame these
delinquents are all part of the infamous
s62 generation a generation with
significantly brutal and powerful
delinquents mikendra introduced that
because the s62 generation would not
usually team up they must have deep
connections with tomin mikey pledges to
fight against hinjiku and plans to
invade yokohama
arriving at tachibana's door takamichi
vows to go back as many times as it
takes to change the future just then
hina arrives home asking if takamichi
has been fighting again as he looks back
to the time he swore to save hina
takamichi smiles saying he keeps on
losing after takamichi informs naoto of
his suspicions of kisaki's time leaping
abilities naoto says that kisaki must be
killed as killing him is the only way to
ensure a guild future unexpectedly naoto
then says he is joking naoto explains
that izana is now one of tommen's top
members a former leader of the black
dragons as naoto plans to investigate
izana through the police network
takamichi decides to investigate as well
takamichi ends up going to the church
where the christmas conflict took place
a man in a neighbouring pew asks him to
be quiet and continues his prayer this
person turns out to be taiju who reveals
that hikai has passed away he tells
takamichi that the old members of tomen
are all dead as he has found a survivor
that may give information about tomen's
past takamichi requests to talk to taiji
about izana and the black dragons
takamichi introduces naoto to taiju
taiju brings them to his restaurant and
tells them that although he has no
intention of collaborating with police
he has a connection with tomin because
of his brother takamichi asks why izana
joined tomen after becoming the leader
of the black dragons in which taju tells
him that he is the order wrong he
reveals that shinichirosano founded the
black dragons and each generation
flourished until izana became the 8th
generation leader because of this izana
is older than taiju as he is part of the
s-62 generation like the others in
tenjiku as he realises that kisaki made
his own way back into toumen takamichi
is confused as kisaki is dead in the
future taiju asks if kisaki is
verifiably dead which prompts naoto to
reveal that izana used his influence
over the police to fake kisaki's death
because maki is dead and kisaki is
overseas izana is effectively thomann's
leader just then koku enters along with
inupi and numerous gang members anyappei
reveals that they are there to abduct
all three of them on the order of izana
taichu tells takamichi inerotu to escape
through the back asking naoto to
investigate hakai's death as he and
naoto run along an alleyway takamichi
thinks about what taiju said to anupan
koko suddenly he is face to face with
the barrel of a gun pointed by kisaki as
kisaki orders takamichi to die naoto
suddenly shoves takamichi out of the
line of sight of fire sustaining the
bullet himself as takamishi cradles a
gravely wounded naoto kisaki remarks on
the carelessness of naoto's attempt to
save takamichi izana tells takamichi
ineoto that they killed his monkey
leaving takamichi confused he then
orders kokucho to kill takamichi as he
lays on the ground dying after being
shot takamuchi apologizes to naoto naoto
reflects that when they first met he was
filled with despair not wanting to put
all his trust in someone as pathetic as
takamichi he was dumbfounded as to why
hina would fall in love with him but
after witnessing takamichi's numerous
failures he believes takamichi is a hero
never giving up regardless as he reaches
out for what he considers their last
handshake he tells takamichi he is proud
of them with both of them tearing up now
to remarks that death is terrifying as
they clasp hands takamichi swears to not
let their handshake be the last
believing that he will never give up
after his time left takaminci rushes to
the tachibana household he meets naoto
outside and desperately shakes his hand
however takamichi shakes his hand to no
avail he cannot time leap to the future
meaning that his trigger in the future
naoto is currently dead grief stricken
takamichi sits at the bottom of a
playground slide he concludes that he
will always fail declaring he is better
off dead suddenly haena appears behind
him on his slide bumping into him gently
she tells takamichi that she loves him
he realizes that he mistook her shadow
for naotos and she has heard everything
that he has just said hina asks
takamichi's actual age and he replies
that he is 26 she says that she will
only ask one more question has takamichi
propose to her in the future
takamichi admits that he has not yet but
he blurts out that it thinks it would be
nice if they got married much to his own
shock when hina asks if that served as a
proposal takamichi answers yes hina
responds that she can now die happy with
his motivation renewed takamichi deduces
that the enemy is izana kudokawa
takamichi decides his present goal is to
find out why mikey will trust izana at
the sano household mikey arrives and
takamichi explains that the leader of
tenjiku is a person named izana kurukawa
maki reveals that he has met izani
before
draken speculates that izana may be
connected to shinichiro as he was a
former black dragon's leader revealing
to takamichi that shinichiro founded the
black dragons but tells takamichi to
keep this fact a secret draken concludes
that izana the eighth generation leader
was the cause of the black dragon's
degradation and reveals that he is her
older brother much to the shock of
everyone else emma explains that the
last time she saw her brother was right
before he was institutionalized
takamichi realises that he signed a
desire to defeat mikey draken suspects
that the black dragon's attack on
kazutora was part of izana's plan to
defeat mikey because he held a personal
grudge against him takamichi calls
shifuyu over to his place and informs
him of the information he gathered at
mikey's house just as he announces the
start of his strategy meeting a honk
outside interrupts them the car window
rolls down revealing the fifth division
captain mucho stepping out of the car
muksho greets takamechi as shifuyu tells
takamichi to watch out tomen's fifth
division steps up restraining all of
takamichi's friends leaving him without
any allies as sakamichi asks what's
going on mucho repeatedly punches him in
the face with takamichi barely
unconscious he hears mucho mention that
izana is giving him busy work takimachi
finds inupi and koko basin and
restrained to cheers enyupay explains to
a confused takamichi that mucho has been
allied with izana all along as he is
part of the es62 generation mucho pulls
a chair up and explains that the tomen's
fifth division has a unique role serving
as the special task division which
enables them to engage in in fighting
calling the fifth division the public
morality council mucho says that the
fifth division serves to punish tomen's
traitors even without mikey's permission
anypay speculates that mucho believes
takamichi is a spy for tenjiku and
brought him and koko into tomen as part
of this military responds that they are
getting worked up over a
misunderstanding and recalls that he
nizana committed crimes together then
formed different gangs and became known
as the s62 generation however izana
stopped in gang activity leaving mikey
to recruit him into towing he explains
to takamichi that he is a founding
member of tenjiku takamichi asks mucho
what he is trying to accomplish mucho
explains that koko is a valuable asset
as he has an aptitude for money making
leaving him desirable to izana mucho
plans to kill inyupay and takamichi
which will force koko to join tenjiko
mushu offers to spare any pay and
takamichi if koko agrees to join tenjiku
however takamichi tells koko that he
should not obey mucho when mucho remarks
that takamichi has no chance of winning
a fight against him although he was
still restrained takamichi charged
demucho after being unconscious for a
while taking which he finds himself atop
a pile of garbage along with inyupay
remembering what transpired and their
fight against mucho after hearing
tokumichi's words anyappei tells him
that he will help takamichi fight mucho
as they rush it mucho he remarks to koko
that they will die unless he chooses to
join tenjihu
just as mucho prepares to punch inupay
koko begs for him to stop promising to
do whatever is required of him
at atonement meeting between mikey and
the members of the first division and
you paid chuckles to himself remarking
that he never thought he would wear
tommen's uniform after mikey learns of
mucho's betrayal takamichi vows that the
first division will devote itself to
rescuing
mikey asks any pay when he suspects
tenjuki will stage their attack in your
pay stays tomorrow on february the 22nd
mikey orders them to gather all of tomon
for a pep rally in preparation
meanwhile kokucho forcefully tells izana
he disagrees with his plan asking why he
would trust hanuman kisaki izana tells
him to shut up as he sees no other way
to defeat tomen draken announces that
tenjiku will attack tourman today they
need to put forth their best effort as
tenjiku will likely fight underhandedly
hakai angrily demands tomen to do the
same explaining that matsuya and smiley
were victims of a motorcycle attack
leaving them unconscious and
hospitalized just then payan revs his
bike telling them to shut up he remarks
that they are cowardly for fearing
defeat though he understands how akai
feels after the attack on matsuya he
tells them to look at mikey as he is not
smiling mikey acknowledges that all the
captains cannot help during this battle
but they can rely on him
with their confidence renewed tomin vows
to crush tenjiku when morning comes
takamichi and inyupay visit shanachiro's
grave when anipe declares takamichi as
the 11th leader of the black dragons
soon after izana approaches them however
takamichi does not recognize him until
in your pace screams izana's name
grabbing him and demanding to know what
he is doing with koko isana calmly
reminds him that koko chose to join
tenjiku and he is just here to visit his
brother's grave he tells inyupay that he
does not care about him anymore as he
now has coco behind them mikey who was
with emma tells inyupay to let go he
orders takamichi to leave with emma
meanwhile hanma sits upon a motorcycle
remarking to kisaki that this is
uncharacteristic of him to get his hands
dirty holding a bat kisaki responds that
he cannot leave this deed to anyone else
from a distance emma and takamichi
watched the graveyard she asks aloud why
do boys have to fight all the time
saying that mikey has always retained a
strong exterior as a gang leader however
she says he is just a child unable to
sleep without his old blanket emma vows
to save mikey just like how he saved her
takamichi realizes that emma's the only
person who can understand and support
mikey emma asks takamichi if he wants a
drink from the vending machine as he
tries to remember if emma exists in the
future kisaki and hanma ride towards
them after takamichi and emma buy their
drinks they see a motorcycle riding
straight towards him in the passenger
seat kisaki screams as he speeds past
takamichi narrowly avoiding him and
strikes emma with a bear still
processing what just occurred sakamichi
sees emma on the ground in shock he
realizes kisaki was targeting emma
before driving away kisaki tells
takamichi that it is over as he cradles
emma's motionless body he realizes
everything he has tried to change thus
far has been for nothing as emma is the
key to saving mikey
crying he begs her to wake up as he can
not save her if she dies in the past
hearing the commotion maki approaches
them and sees emma on the ground mikey
asks what happened in takamishi explains
that emma was hit in a drive-by biker
attack perpetrated by tessa kasaki mikey
tells takamichi to sit emma on his back
as they walk to the hospital maggie asks
if she remembers the last time he
carried her when she was five she broke
her leg chasing him emma begins to
instruct mikey on what to do if
something happens to her requesting
mikey to tell draken that she loves him
as her eyes well up with tears emma
tells a crying takamichi to take care of
mikey for her just before her body
slumps in death
panicked mikey tries to reveal to emma
that draken has mutual feelings for her
telling her that he will call him as
soon as they reach the hospital and
hopes that she will wake up however she
does not respond trembling mikey tells
takamichi to put his jacket over her as
she is getting cold
mikey is silent when draken asks what
happened he angrily punches mike in the
face demanding as to why he let this
happen takamichi begins to raise him
with drakken
telling him to overcome and accept the
events however
he realizes the absurdity of this as he
has been unable to accept hina's death
himself defeated takamichi knows he
cannot reverse this fate as tomin awaits
their leader at the shrine they wonder
what is going on just then inupi pulls
up on his motorcycle informing them of
the events
at the hospital mikey is still in his
catatonic state having lost the will to
fight takamichi vows to fight tenjiku
even if he has to face them alone shifu
meets takamichi outside of the hospital
bringing him to the shrine where tomen
is waiting they announced that emma has
died in an accident which means neither
mikey nor draken will be able to fight
however he insists that they fight
tenjiku tonight which angers tomen
causing them to turn their backs on him
having originally planned to fight alone
he tells shifu that he is going to fight
tenjiku even if he has to do so alone
shifu offers to fight alongside him
though he expects both of them to die at
tenshiku's hands just then akun exclaims
to takamichi that he is going to fight
with him as well as takamichi never runs
away from a fight prompting yamageshi
makoto and takuya all to agree to fight
with them
shifuyu tells tomen that although the
odds are against them running away would
ensure the end of tomen leaving them
with no choice but to fight this riles
up tomen as they chant in support
takamachi tells shifuyu that he wants to
save emma and baji as well believing
nothing is impossible not long after
footsteps announced toman's arrival led
by shifuyu and takamichi hizaki tells
takamichi that he has been waiting once
again calling him hero izana points out
tommen's disadvantage in the battle as
tenjiku outnumbers tomen 450.
he calls up shion as their forerunner
payon steps up telling shion to face him
he reminds takamichi that he is the
acting president of the third division
xion interrupts payan saying that he can
defeat all of tomen alone
unexpectedly payan knocks out xion with
a single punch after this with takamichi
as the acting leader tomin charges at
tenjiku to begin their fight takamichi
shouts to kisaki and they both agree to
settle their battle tonight izana
watches the battle he remarks that he is
impressed
he stomps on shion's unconscious face
remarking that the black dragons lost to
mikey because of shion's weakness
although he says he does not usually
engage in revenge isana asks payan to
fight him when payan eagerly charges
towards him isana kicks him in the face
knocking him out with a single blow
shocked takamishi realizes isana's true
strength
as takamichi charges at kikucho he is
easily thrown to the ground kokucho
tells him he is weak asking if he is
just talk takamichi tells him to let him
fight kisaki kukuchu tells him that he
will stand as an obstacle until he is
defeated seeing takamichi on the ground
shifuyu rushes to assist him but he is
blocked by mochi who punches him telling
him not to be distracted
meanwhile anypay tells mucho to move as
he wants to talk to koko just as he says
this mucho easily overpowers nup
as inupi cries out in pain mucho sits
atop him telling inyupay that he is
defeated hikai and angry attempt to back
each other up in their fight against
rindo and ran winikai asks angry says
his arm may be broken brendo mocks this
telling angry he will break another
additional limb watching this shifu says
that since they are both the baby of the
family they are used to being pampered
amid hakai in angry's argument the
hatani brothers knock both of them to
the ground mocking them for depending on
their older siblings laying on the
ground hakai and angry look for their
siblings once again but conclude that it
cannot be helped they realise their
shared weaknesses and reliance on others
this motivates their drive to fight
standing up they prepare to face the
hatani brothers once again charging
towards them brindu and ran their
brothers easily bring the duo to the
ground as angry remarks his older
brother would have avoided rondo's
tackle rindo grabs a hold of his left
leg breaking it as angry cries out in
pain as angry crawls barely able to move
angry watches desperately as rindu grabs
sakai's arm while ran hits his face with
a baton he believes that hikai will die
from their relentless attacks and begins
crying begging the brothers to stop
meanwhile smiley tells matsuya that
angry is a good person basing up others
doesn't come naturally to him however he
adds when angry starts crying his nature
changes as he has the limits that caused
the ogre to come out facing the hitani
brothers a crying angry tells them that
they went too far
apologizing to his older brother for
breaking his promise both ran and rendo
are surprised to find angry standing as
his leg was broken smiley tells matsuya
that as the crying blue ogre the angry
is over 100 times stronger than himself
brendo eagerly tackles angry however
much to his surprise angry does not
budge
angry tells him that he last cried
during his fourth year of elementary
school his brother told him not to cry
again as he would become a murderer if
he did so angry knocks out rindo in a
single punch much to the shock of
everyone around them the tenjiku members
witnessed this with confusion causing
mochi to abandon his fight with shifuyu
to fight angry
putting his arm around angry mochi
remarks that he can beat him alone just
before angry slams mochi's head into the
ground with a punch
as he cries angry asks the fearful
tenshiku members who is next mucho steps
up simultaneously they grab each other's
arms however angry overpowers mucho
slamming him onto the ground as inyapai
shifuyu angry takamichi and hikai stand
up believing that they have the
advantage mucho stands up remembering an
order izana relayed to him swinging her
blade mucho announces that he has no
intention to lose just before he stabs
takamichi kokucho stands between them
grabbing mucho's blade kokucho punches
him telling mucho that he does not want
him to be ruined by tenjiku confused
takamichi and his friends wonder if
kokucho is their ally kikucho tells
takamichi that he is not the same person
he knew in elementary school
kokuto quickly dispatches angry shifuyu
and inyupay as he watches izani remarks
that the other heavenly kings are
useless in comparison with most of
tomen's members exhausted and defeated
kokucho tells takamechi that now he
comprises tomin facing kokucho takamichi
tells him that although he has gotten
stronger he is now a member of a brutal
criminal organization
standing over india pay coco remarks
that takamichi as well as inyupay's
dreams for the black dragons will be
easily defeated
shifuyu unable to move panics about
takamichi's safety takamichi gets up
again remarking that kucho has not
changed as he still punches like he did
when he was a child justice inyupay
tells koko that takamichi will never
lose kokucho tells him to prepare to die
punching him again just as kokucho
prepares to deliver his final blow
shifuyu leaps in between the two crying
he implores takamichi to accept defeat
as no one from tomen is left standing if
tokomichi continues fighting he will die
with his face swollen and bloody
takamichi screams insisting that tomen
will never be defeated as long as he is
there
in reaction kisaki tells kokucho to move
over asking if takamichi has the
determination to win even if he dies
kisaki points a gun at his head
takamichi reflects back on his lack of
fear as the encouragement and
self-sacrifice of countless people after
takamichi asks hisaki what is holding
him back a shot rings out however kisaki
cannot bring himself to kill takamichi
shooting him in the foot instead
takamichi vows not to give up even at
the cost of his death as kisaki holds a
gun to takamiji's head threatening to
kill him takamichi eggs him on telling
him it should be easy since he has
already killed emma in response kisaki
pulls away his gun and punches takamichi
in the face
just then akun grabs him supporting him
to stand he reminds takamechi that he is
not the type to give up shifuyu tells
takamichi that he is glad he took over
bhaji's role turning to kisaki he says
that although he wants revenge for
bhaji's death their battle should not
become fatal
his psyche angrily retorts that their
resolve does not change the fact that
tomen is losing he then proposes that
tenchiku and tobin merge under tommen's
name upon hearing this takamichi punches
kisaki in the face telling him that he
will beat him up until he understands
takamichi prepares to punch him once
again however izana blocks his punch
telling hisaki to move out of the way as
he will kill all of tomon takamichi
tries to think of a reason as to why
mahi would turn evil he concludes that
tenjiku's influence caused mikey's
downfall carefully he swears to protect
mikey just as he is about to punch izana
takamichi suddenly stops having detected
someone's arrival
raising his fist in the air he asks what
took mikey so long he then reminds
everyone of his promise not to lose
everyone is astounded by mikey's
appearance as takamishi cries tears of
relief monkey hugs him thanking him
however takamichi is still concerned
about mikey as he should not be in the
right mental state just then the sound
of draken's motorcycle signals his
arrival as takamichi questions why both
of them are here hina is revealed to be
with them earlier after takamichi left
the hospital pena requested to talk with
a distraught mikey
anna confesses that takamechi is trying
to save a lot of people at once she
explains that she will die in 12 years
and that takamichi came from the future
to save her
though they may not believe her
takamichi's palable desperation confirms
this crying hina says that although
takamichi wants to save everyone she is
powerless to help him
this brings mikey and draken out of
their despair as they remember the
numerous times takamichi tried to save
tomen
mikey asks the tenkiku members if they
are handicapped prompting them to
angrily tell mikey and drakken that they
are the ones who are handicapped
demanding that the situation be taken
more seriously mikey responds that
tenjiku are the ones that should take
them more seriously declaring that he
can take down twenty thousand men
turning to kisaki
remarks that his plan probably did not
go as expected suddenly izani rushes
towards mikey landing a kick on his face
just then mikey releases his signature
kick however izana blocks it just before
complimenting mikey on his skills after
this happens a third time takamichi
realizes the true strength of izana
izana says that despite mikey's
impressive fighting prowess his moves
are easy to read much to everyone's
shock just as izana punches mikey once
more mikey asks why he killed their
sister he tells mikey he plans to kill
all of tomen and shape a distraught
mikey into shinichiro when mikey asks if
that is the reason he killed emma izana
responds by delivering a kick that
throws mikey onto the ground
standing over him izana says that mikey
took everything away from him so he must
kill him
while mikey blocks izana's kicks he
tells izana he is wrong as they both
still have a brother after mikey tells
izana that he wants to save him isana
angrily tells him to shut up kicking him
however mikey avoids the attack
remarking to izana that he is starting
to miss he then punches and kicks izana
in succession bringing him to the ground
izani remarks that he is finally
enjoying the fight as mikey's power
poses a formidable challenge
mikey dodges izana's punch and instead
strikes izana in the chest as he rushes
towards mikey with his fist mikey
punches him izana recoils from the
attack and visualizes shinachiro and
emma standing with mikey when mikey
tells izana he lost he screams grabbing
kisaki's gun and pointing it at mikey
mikey asks izana if he will lose
everything after he loses the fight
crying isana thinks back to his mother
who abandoned him with tears in her eyes
she told izana to stay strong despite
his solitude upon seeing izana points a
gun at mikey takamichi calls out telling
izana that using a gun is cheap izana
tells mikey to die but mikey is unfazed
iggy and onizana telling him to shoot
an anxious draken implores mikey to be
careful as izana seems serious mikey
continues screaming at his hand at a
shoe but just then kakuto slaps the gun
out of izana's hand telling izana to
accept kinjiku's loss angrily izana
demands if kakucho his servant is giving
advice to him a king shakin izana
kokucho tells him that none of tenjuku's
members can win their battles loudly
repeating that tenjiku has lost as izana
screams for him to shut up kisaki
suddenly shoots kikucho in the chest
splattering blood on izana's face and
remarking that he is annoying when
kikucho lunges akisaki kisaki fires his
gun telling kikucho to die
unexpectedly his either leaps in front
of the stream of bullets protecting
kokutsu through the shock of everyone
including kasaki who falls to the ground
in surprise
lying on the ground kokuchu asks izana
what he is doing next to him isana tells
him that his body just moved on its own
as he is dying izana says he wants to
tell mikey something he remarks that
tenshiku has lost and kikucho tells him
that he does not have to say it as it
has already been announced crying
kikuchu asks his ana why he protected
him as he is worthless while izana is a
king who wanted to build a new era izana
corrects him telling kikucho that it was
this era smiling he says that kokucho is
the only person he has izana asks mikey
if he wanted to save him and mikey
responds saying that he did as izana is
his brother izana reveals to mikey that
he is not blood related to anyone crying
he tells mikey that there is no way to
save him and as he dies he utters emma's
name poncin izana's motionless body
kikucho cries grasping his hand he tells
izana that he will not be alone in death
as he will be joining him soon upon
seeing kikucho and izan emotionless
mikey announces the end of the tomen
tenjuku dispute turning his attention to
kosaki mikey tells him he will never be
forgiven
just then hana rides up on his
motorcycle grabbing kisaki and escaping
as takamichi powerly watches them right
away draken tells takamichi to get on
his bike to chase them down as he and
takamichi gain ground on hama and kisaki
draken vows to catch them on hunma's
bike kisaki implores him to drive faster
suddenly hanuma loses control of the
bike throwing him and kisaki to the
ground when hisaki looks up he finds
takamichi standing over him kisaki
instantly runs away and when takamichi
tries chasing him the pain of his foot
overwhelms him dracon pulls him up
ordering takamichi to get on his back
just then hammer catches up to the pier
swinging a metal pipe at drakken
although draken counters the attack he
is now preoccupied with fighting hanma
as takamichi chases kisaki around the
corner hisaki attacks his head with a
brick but takamichi punches kisaki in
response takaminchi ends up chasing
kisaki into a parking lot where they
punch each other in quick succession as
they both catch their breath takamichi
notes that he recognizes the area
takamichi tells kisaki to give up and
accept their loss saying that all he
does is manipulate and use others unable
to do anything by himself while he
budding takamichi kasaki explains that a
perfect plan is the way to achieve his
goals as takamichi leaps upon kisaki he
asks if the perfect plan was intended to
defeat him they wrestle in the parking
lot with kisaki ending up on top he
angrily says that he is supposed to be
the dark hero strangling takamichi
kisaki says that all his plans started
perfectly but there was someone who
always ruined them takamichi kicks
kisaki away from him he explains that he
remembers when he was last at the
parking lot standing in front of a fire
he had sworn to become the top of tomen
takamichi tells kisaki that the parking
lot was where hisaki killed hanyu in the
future he tells kisaki that they will
settle their time leaping battle upon
hearing this kisaki remarks that his
suspicions are confirmed takamichi is a
time leaper suddenly a scene depicting
kisaki and heine appears in takamichi's
mind takamichi asks what kisaki's
involvement with hina is as he killed
hina in every timeline hearing this
kisaki solemnly says that he failed
visualizing the future scene takamichi
sees kisaki proposing to hina however
she apologizes turning him down before
takamichi can finish comprehending this
kisaki points a gun at him telling
takamichi that their fate ends now
pointing his gun at takamichi kasaki
demands to know why takamichi always
thwarts his plans and how many times he
has leaped when takamichi asks if he
killed hina after her rejections this
enrages kisaki who insists that hina
belongs to him
all of a sudden takamichi kicks the gun
out of kiysaki's hand and grabs her
pointing at akisaki he tells hisaki that
it should have been him holding the gun
from the beginning before telling kisaki
to die takamichi points a gun at kisaki
prepare to shoot as he believes he can
save hina by killing him just then hina
and mikey show up to the scene with
takamichi briefly distract by heinous
shouts hisaki takes this opportunity to
run as takamichi chases after him he
tells kisaki that it is over as no one
will trust him anymore when which kisaki
responds saying that he can start over
again swearing to make hina his someday
takamichi says he will not let that
happen
telling hisaki that he will not even let
him timely again
upon hearing this kisaki stops in the
middle of a crosswalk asking if
takamichi still thinks that he is a time
leaper takamichi is surprised by this
fact but before kisaki can explain a
truck crashes into him after he is
struck by the truck kisaki lays in the
intersection when he tried to get up his
man good body prevented him from doing
so screaming at his agony and
powerlessness hisaki says that he does
not want to die as his body becomes
motionless mikey and hina catch up with
mikey asking what happened with kisaki's
death the kanto incident ends the
remaining s-62 members are arrested
while the three deaths are emasano izana
kudakawa and tetekasaki the participants
of the kanto incident are left to
somberly reflect on the events
following hanukkah's triumph against his
enemy tedekisaki and successfully
altering the present to save the lives
of his loved ones takamichi confesses to
mikey about his time travelling
abilities and his mission
mikey believes him and subsequently
summons the members of tomen to announce
its disbandment
through mixed feelings the gang
universally agrees with the decision
later the tobin captains gather for a
time capsule promising to meet again
takamichi meets with hina who blames
herself for causing the death of emma
due to kisaki's obsession takamichi
comforts her and proposes they marry in
12 years to which she accepts much to
naoto's own surprise takamichi returns
to the prison with all his friends
celebrating the wedding of parchin
however absent from all of them is maki
himself dracon and shifuyu state mikey
runs a successful chain of restaurants
and was busy overseas with work
takamichi later visits mitsuya shot who
is responsible for hina's wedding dress
hikai and yuzuha also enter the shop and
the group reminisces
takamichi returns to his normal life
realizing he is now the manager of the
record store and his former boss but
still living in the same old dirty
apartment takamichi watches the news of
the organization bontine and notices the
hanafuda-like tattoo on one of its
members takamichi and hina visit smiley
and angry's ramen restaurant while
talking takamichi sees the photo of
tomen's disbandment and inquires about
mikey but neither of them know anything
as they haven't met in over 10 years
stating that the only information they
have is from draken as takamichi sees
hina's earrings he suddenly remembers
the tattoo from the bontine member is
incredibly similar to those used by
izana kudokawa having a bad feeling
takamichi storms out of the restaurant
and goes to confront draken over what he
knows from mikey drakken reveals that
both him and shifuyu lied to takamechi
so that he could be happy and warns him
against mikey for he has become
unrecognizably evil takamichi meets with
naoto with the letter informing him
about bonten the current worst criminal
organization in japan involved in
gambling fraud prostitution and murder
naoto subsequently informs that bontin's
leader is not izana but his brother
mikey leaving takamichi in shock at the
same time santo who is an executive of
bontin is seen murdering traitors on
mikey's order takamichi is stuck in
disbelief that mikey could have turned
out evil and requests to shake hands
with naoto again nato is reluctant but
eventually concedes however no time
leaping occurs and naoto theorizes that
the trigger for the ability is a strong
desire to change the current time and
naoto no longer feels any desire to do
so since his sister is safe takamichi
later meets with shifuyu and reveals
that he can no longer time leave shifuyu
approves of this for he has achieved his
mission of saving hina takamishi asks if
he knows anything about how mikey turned
evil to which shifuyu responds he tried
to find out but wasn't able to so he
tries to cheer up takamichi by saying
that it is the path that mikey has
chosen and that he is his own wedding to
look forward to overhearing the
conversation kazutura appears and
believes mikey is the same as always but
unable to show his vulnerabilities
because he has taken a path that he
himself did not choose and they too
agree to try and find mikey months later
takamichi has a haircut from akon as
takamichi laments the lack of progress
akuna assures him that him and his
friends are searching but have been
unable for bontine as extremely
dangerous takamichi asks that they stop
instead vowing to find maki himself he
soon gets a call from hakai who proposes
that they open the time capsule this
home and captains meet except for mikey
and the group decides to open the time
capsule reminiscing about the past while
reading their letters draken reveals
that he had mixed feelings about the
disbarment for he never wanted tomen to
end and believes the dismantment hurt
mikey much more but believes that emma
will always be in his heart the group
decides to read mikey's letter which has
him accurately predict everyone's future
occupations and revealing he disbanded
tomen for takamichi's sake and to secure
everyone's future so that they could
learn and prepare for adulthood reading
this the group is put at ease knowing
that they are still connected around the
same time kokucho asks mikey if him not
going to the anniversary was the right
decision to which mikey says it was as
the group leaves takamichi realizes that
they forgot to read his letter to which
he also finds a videotape revealed to
have been put there by mikey with a
message to future takamichi the message
reveals mikey's conflict over his dark
impulses that were kept on check by
shinochiro emma and bhaji and now he's
terrified of what he can become he
wishes takamichi to have a good life and
to not look for him takamichi realizes
mikey's descent to evil is not external
and was caused due to mikey succumbing
to his own darkness kasatur appears with
a lead or mikey but takamichi rejects it
saying it is mikey's wish for him to not
be found takamichi meets with the group
at mitsuya's shop with haina doning the
wedding dress after takamichi goes with
hina and tries on her dress he goes on a
frantic mission to find more information
about mikey's location but is tossed out
from a store as they don't want any
trouble kasithora is concerned about his
sudden rush to find mikey and counters
him to stop engaging on a suicide
mission for he has a wedding in three
days takamichi finds himself in an
abandoned bowling alley and one of
bontin's bases thinking he cannot meet
mikey he suddenly finds a gun pointed to
his head by sanzu as mikey himself
appears in person maki asks about
takamichi's intentions takamichi replies
that he wants to invite everyone to his
wedding and just like mikey had planned
everyone's futures is the best except
for his sansu threatens to shoot but
mikey has them retire so they too can
talk alone takamichi asks about maki's
dark impulses believing it was kisaki's
involvement and shinachiro's death that
turned him evil subsequently revealing
he could no longer time leap fahina has
been saved takamichi is grateful to
mikey for securing everyone's future but
now it's his turn to save maki to which
the latter responds by shooting him from
behind mikey chastises takamichi for
looking for him knowing that it would
end with this result stating his journey
is over admits takamichi's protests that
he will save him mikey reveals he plans
to end everything after this mikey walks
to the roof having visions of shinachiro
emma and bhaji he looks down to people
and imagines tomin gathered there
surprisingly mikey decides to jump to
commit suicide but while falling is
grabbed by immortally wounded takamichi
takamichi implores mikey to save himself
for he has little strength left with
mikey protesting about for what he is
doing and that he should let him die
takamishi opposes this decision saying
he will do anything that he can to save
him to which mikey points out that he
can no longer time leap and asks him to
put him at peace takamichi tells him to
shut up and stop burdening himself and
to let himself ask for help even if it's
just once
seeing his determination mikey breaks
down tearfully asking takamichi to save
him in that moment takamichi finds
himself transported to the past once
more to june 06 2008
getting ready for high school sometime
during 2008 hanuma visits kisaki's grave
remembering all the way from his board
days basing out people to when he first
met kisaki to all of kisaki's plans up
to his death unma mourned him praising
him for not pulling any punches leaving
a beer bottle on his grave he says that
he fulfilled his promise and declares
his intentions to start something
well so i'm not gonna lie that was
absolutely huge and took me so long to
get through i'm sorry i forgot a little
bit dry out points in there as my voice
was kind of giving out as you could
imagine it took me like six hours of on
and off recording just to record the
audio itself for this and then a lot
more alone with uh just editing the
audio not even talking about editing the
video so this was a absolutely huge
video on my behalf so if you guys have
enjoyed it and watched the entire video
and want to see more stuff like this
then be sure to hit that subscribe
button and uh you know leave a like on
the video as well and if you guys want
to start off at the three deities arc
which is the last arc so far in tokyo
avengers
then you could start off from either 206
which is where we left off with sanju
being slaughtered down by the third wolf
or you could start off with 207 which is
the very star of the last arc but
obviously like i i recommend that you do
pick up the manga and read it as well
like this is pretty much entirely what
happens throughout the manga i know i
forgot a few moments that happened
throughout it and and left a few things
here and there out just so i can shorten
things down overall but this is you know
like pretty much what happens throughout
the entire series so far that we've been
given down to even some of the uh lines
themselves you know like i recommend
that you pick up the manga it's like
honestly it's it's literally amazing and
it's blowing my mind and brought me to
tears more times than you know i can
possibly even remember even like reading
the script here and going through it
it's been absolutely amazing being able
to go back through the story i've also
got to thank a few people from my
discord as i wouldn't have been able to
do this video without their help as they
really helped out with you know sourcing
a lot of the stuff for
um certain chapters for me and all that
kind of jazz and also you know shout out
to the tokyo avengers fan and wiki as
that pretty much has you know like a
detailed explanation on what happens
throughout every single chapter and i
really wouldn't have been able to do the
majority of this video without that so
make sure you guys do check all that
kind of stuff out but if you do want to
keep up to date with the latest tokyo
avengers content and a lot more just
like i guess anime videos in general
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really helps out with
the algorithm and pushes my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people plus as i've
said this video has taken me ages so you
know i wouldn't be able to thank you
enough but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate dear voila and i
will see you all and either bye
you